so I've been reading the Twilight Saga a
series of vampire romance novels by
someone called Stephanie Meyer and I
have oh just a couple thoughts I know a
lot has been said about Twilight but
this is a complex work there's depths to
Twilight that we as a society haven't
even begun to explore so let's get into
it most of you know what Twilight is but
I should explain the basics for new
people Stephanie Meyer was by all
accounts a boor Mormon housewife when on
June 2nd 2003 around 4: in the morning
she awoke from a vivid dream about a
girl and a boy in a meadow having this
conversation about how they were in love
and the difficulties in that because he
wanted to kill her he was a vampire a
boy and a girl in the meadow having this
conversation about how they were in love
and the difficulties in that because he
wanted to kill her he was a vampire that
dream became the first of four novels
Twilight New Moon eclipse and Breaking
Dawn which were made into five films in
2015 Stephanie published life and death
a gender swapped reimagining of the
first novel yes she transgendered
Twilight Twilight has gone woke and in
2020 she published midnight sun which is
just the first novel again but from
Dracula's perspective Twilight has been
on Trend again recently I mean I'm
talking about it so honestly it was more
on Trend when I started this video but
the script took me 18 months Twilight
took me 3 months to write so in the
2000s these books about a teenage girl
being seduced by various creatures of
the night spent 235 weeks on the best
seller list for children and as you can
imagine there was discourse vampires
need love too that is world news for
this Sunday I'm John Burman for all of
us at ABC news thanks for watching good
night Twilight's one of those pop
culture phenomena from the 2000s that
was intensely loved and then intensely
hated and then 10 years later it got
re-evaluated and everyone's like do we
really need to hate this thing so much
you know like gay people or 9/11 some
critics have suggested that Twilight was
hated so much because of misogyny and
that's definitely true you know people
love to hate whatever teenage girls are
into Jacob I remember when Twilight came
out boys really hated that Stephanie
Meyer had feminized vampire lore by
making Edward Sparkle you know cuz Count
Dracula was always so Butch you should
clue the and yet the truly devoted
Twilight haters have always been women
Twilight is a romance novel and as long
as romance novels have existed women
have always been the majority of readers
but also the harshest critics hating on
romance novels is as much a part of
feminine culture as reading them in 1856
yes video essays are pretentious yes
it's very funny let's all laugh in 1856
maryan Evans known by her masculine pen
name George Elliot and often considered
one of the greatest novelists of all
time wrote an essay called silly novels
by lady novelists in which she
complained that lady novelists write
unrealistic wish fulfillment fantasy
schlock with absurd Mary Sue self-insert
protagonists who every man falls in love
with you know all the same complaints
that people make today about romance
fiction it is clear that they write in
elegant BDO with violet colored ink and
a ruby
that they must be entirely indifferent
to Publishers accounts and inexperienced
in every form of poverty except Poverty
of brains there is a level of
internalized misogyny in this the not
likee other girls urge to identify with
men and share in men's contempt for
women that is misogyny but to Simply
dismiss hatred of Twilight as
misogynistic is too simple because the
criticism is usually not just that
Twilight is feminine and frivolous that
it's written with violet colored ink and
Ruby pen but also that vampire romance
intertwines love and violence here was
this guy and he was in love with her but
he wanted to kill her and that Twilight
is therefore somehow dangerous is this
true is Twilight dangerous well Edward
Cullen is the world's most dangerous
predator I'm the world's most dangerous
predator he's a killer I'm a killer he's
killed people before I've killed people
before he wanted to kill you I wanted to
kill kill you he still don't know if I
can control himself I still don't know
if I can control myself he's designed to
kill I'm designed to
kill I don't care baby Robert patson in
his little peacoat saying I am designed
to kill is my favorite thing ever how
can you not love this this is the skin
of a killer Bella this is the skin of a
killer Bella now am I saying the
Twilight books are the greatest work of
art ever produced yes
[Music]
[Applause]
part one
fiction it has been said that Edward
Cullen is an
abuser but that's an understatement he's
not just an abuser he's a serial killer
I've killed people
before many people are Disturbed that
Twilight is a romance and yet the hero
is dangerous and obsessive and capable
of violence what if I'm not the hero
what if I'm the bad guy in other words
they're Disturbed that it's the average
romance novel I don't have the strength
to stay away from you anymore and no not
every romance novel has a bad boy hero
but it's one of the most common tropes
vampires Need Love Too critics point to
things like the age Gap I'm 109 maybe I
shouldn't be dating such an old man it's
gross and the stalking so you followed
me I like watching you sleep and the
gaslighting you hit your head I think
you're confused I know what I saw it's
the fluoresence and when Twilight was at
the peak of popularity there were all
these articles a hand ringing about the
potential of all this to corrupt the
youth Twilight is not not feminist said
the guardian it's female masochism 50
shades for teenage girls except with
vampires all these articles that cited
the same live Journal post that went
down a checklist from the National
Domestic Violence Hotline to prove that
Edward Cullen is an
abuser there's always some version of
this discourse going on women are
reading the wrong books the books that
women read are dangerous in the 2000s it
was Twilight and in the 2010s it was the
Twilight fanfiction 50 Shades of Gray at
the time I'm making this video it's a
novelist called Colleen Hoover Who Sold
6 trillion books about dangerous alpha
males named Riley I promise that in
whatever year you're watching this video
there's currently some lady novelist
who's caused an outrage writing stories
about a dangerous wealthy controlling
alpha male he doesn't do romance I don't
do Romance but the female protagonist
awakens his capacity for Love at the
same time as he awakens her desire for
sex now I don't want to dismiss the
feelings of people who find this kind of
romance disturbing I think it's healthy
and normal to be uncomfortable whenever
sexuality and violence are intertwined
so I'm not exactly disagreeing with
these critics of Twilight and of dark
romance in general I'm yes anding them
yes Edward Cullen is creepy he's a
vampire if Edward Cullen were real I
would log onto Twitter and I would
cancel that vampire I'd call the police
and I would say hello 911 I'd like to
report a coven of vampires outside Forks
Washington yes they've smashed many
salads yes Edward is problematic yes and
Edward is not real right he can't hurt
you it's going to be okay Edward Cullen
is a fictional character in a woman's
fantasy and I do feel that that is
relevant to how we analyze his behavior
the main line of argument against
Twilight is that this type of story
normalizes and romanticizes abusive
relationship Dynamics it's a monkey see
monkey do theory of media analysis this
moralistic Cinema Sins thing everyone is
doing now ageg gaps ding stalking ding
andant an asde a
ding this idea that if people read Rao
fanfiction this will somehow normalize
relationships with Sith Lords are twins
going to jump off a cliff because Bella
does I say the obsessive moral policing
of the romance genre as a continuation
of literally centuries of concern that
women are reading the wrong kinds of
books when I was young in the 18th
century ladies were advised to read what
we called conduct books such as Thomas
gisburn an inquiry into the duties of
the female sex which instructed the
reader in proper feminine virtues
doesn't that sound exciting to indulge
in a practice of reading novels is
liable to produce mischievous effects a
certain kind of person has always
considered romance novels sort of
decadent and salacious some of this
comes down to a question about the the
purpose of art is Art supposed to be a
moral education that instructs the
reader in proper virtuous conduct or B a
mirror of reality that reflects life as
it really is or C Escapist fantasy
that's primarily entertainment
throughout the history of the novel The
genre has often been dismissed as
Escapist fantasy literary opium an
addictive corrupting influence the first
bestselling English novel ever was a
romance published in 1740 by Samuel
Richardson called Pamela or virtue
rewarded Pamela tells the story of a
virtuous 15-year-old girl named Pamela
Andrews who employed as a maid servant
by the wealthy pervert Mr B who
repeatedly attempts to seduce her kidnap
her sneak into her room at night and the
whole time Pamela is like nay I Shan
aquest this Li sensious rake for my
innocence and virtue are more dear to me
than my life and if the cost be my
Felicity so be it for I sh subject my
poor mother and father to the ignominy
of in the end Mr B is so impressed with
Pamela's virtue that he reforms his
rakish ways and marries her which is
supposed to be the reward I guess for
Pamela's chased Behavior it's a
Cinderella rags to Rich's fantasy with a
prince charming who's not so Charming
Pamela is kind of like an 18th century
50 Shades of Gray Mr B will see you now
you could also make an argument that
Pamela was the novel with the first
modern fandom there was Pamela
fanfiction and Pamela merch there was
discourse between pamus and anti- pamus
about the sincerity of Pamela's virtue
anti- pamus wrote parody novels like
Eliza Haywood's anti- Pamela or fed
innocence Detective wow what a Savage
burn and Henry fielding's
shamela both of which reframe Pamela as
a gold digging social climber this must
have been an affront Samuel Richardson
who makes his position clear on the
cover page claiming that he published
Pamela quote in order to cultivate the
principles of virtue and religion in the
minds of the Youth of both sexes so in
1740 there was already this tension
between two purposes of Art is Art
supposed to inflame the mind or is it
supposed to cultivate the principles of
virtue and religion in the minds of the
youth personally I prefer to be inflamed
I want to feel good I don't want to be
good and Stephanie Meyer apparently
agrees I never stop and think you know
oh this is a role model for people it's
fiction it is fiction whatever we think
of its morality Pamela became the
template for romance novels where a
young inexperienced impoverished girl
becomes the object of Fascination for an
older richer man with a dangerous edge
in the 19th century Pride and Prejudice
and Jane air both fit this description
The Pride and Prejudice is obviously
much more agreeable to 21st century
morality than Pamela Fitz William Darcy
is not Elizabeth Bennett's sexually
abusive boss he's not even a vampire you
should have thought of that Jane Austin
what are you doing in the 20th Century
the term romance novel became associated
with mass Market paperback romances
derogatorily known as bodice rippers
like Joanna Lindsay's gentle Rogue with
the classic Fabio clinch on the cover
they don't do covers like this anymore
here's the new edition of gentle Rogue
with the most boring cover imaginable
red ver red ver to the clinch covers we
used to be a country a proper country
the genzi equivalent of bodice rippers
is like Wat BTS werewolf thick how many
Mafia twinks can there be the
specifically feminist criticism of
romance novels goes back at least to
Germaine Greer who included a long rant
about them in her 1970 Manifesto the
female unic in which she condemns
romance readers as women cherishing the
chains of their own bondage the point
I'm trying to make is there's a
historical continuity from Pamela to
Twilight Stephanie Meyer's contribution
is that she took the classic romance
formula combined it with the lurid
sexiness of Dracula and then Mormon ised
it to the point it became appealing to
21st century teenagers and moms another
continuity from Pamela to Twilight is
the persistent anxiety of critics that
the romance novel is somehow corrupting
the youth or enslaving women or both
Aaron meanly worries about Twilight
quote some girls might expect their love
life to look just like Bella's Now
That's What I Call scary naha Gandhi
says Bella is essentially a romanticized
version of all our worst weakest
impulses put up on a pedestal and that
makes her dangerous with a lot of
criticism of Twilight you get the
impression that the critic both senses
the attraction to Twilight and is
uncomfortable with that attraction and
the anxious hand ringing is a
manifestation of that ambivalence even
Germaine Greer admits quote I cannot
claim to be fully emancipated from the
dream that some enormous man say 6'6
heavily shouldered and so forth to match
will crush me to his Tweeds look down
into my eyes and leave the taste of
heaven or The Scorch of his passion on
my waiting lips remember what they took
from you I want to argue that both the
fascination with vampire romance and the
discomfort with it are natural reactions
to something paradoxical in the
experience erence of erotic love itself
Twilight is everything we fear in
sexuality the excess the irrationality
the transgression the violence the loss
of self-possession the violation of
boundaries none of them belong to
themselves anymore and the sickest part
is the genes tell them they're happy
about it Stephanie Meyer is continuing
an ancient mythological tradition of
Storytelling that equates Love and Death
think Hades and and pany the temptation
of Eve Swan Lake Romeo and Juliet like
Romeo and Juliet Twilight is in moderate
Teenage Love escalated to the point of
death and you could argue that Romeo and
Juliet are closer to equals where Edward
and Bella are predator in prey the lion
fell in love with the lamb so the lion
fell in love with the lamb but look at
the big picture in Twilight the lamb
doesn't stay a lamb by the end of the
story she becomes a lion she's a
powerful vampire with a rich husband and
a magical demon baby yes Edward is a
dangerous predator but his power is
subservient to his love for Bella and
it's deployed for her protection I feel
very protective of you she becomes
powerful because he loves her this is
not a story of becoming prey it's a
story of rising to the level of the
Predator behind every Cinderella fantasy
is a female Will To
Power the debates about romance fiction
are not frivolous they concern the
deepest questions in women's lives what
does happiness look like what do we want
from Love from sex what does it mean to
succeed as a woman what does it mean to
be a woman what does it mean to be
anything why is is Twilight like this to
answer these questions and more I read
the entire Twilight Saga twice I watched
the movies 37 times I read 3,000 pages
of psychoanalysis and 8,000 pages of
queer and radical feminist Theory now
some people say that I'm overly fixated
on Twilight that mother is having
another episode and maybe some of those
people are my psychiatrist and maybe
they're trying to put me on mood
stabilizers but here's by those people
are
wrong part two desire one way to State
the question the mystery we're trying to
solve is why would someone romanticize
the relationship between a vampire and a
human between a predator and his prey
isn't this problematic with its age gaps
and its power dynamics one answer is
that yes it is problematic and it's
problematic because in order for a story
to have a plot there needs to be a
problem what is sometimes known as a
conflict conflict creates tension both
romantic and narrative and in Twilight
Edward's vampirism is the source of that
tension listen to how Stephanie Meyers
summarizes the dream that inspired
Twilight a boy and a girl in a meadow
having this conversation about how they
were in love and the difficulties in
that because he wanted to kill her he
was a vampire that that is a problem yes
you're right the danger of Edward
wanting to kill Bella adds to the
tension it makes the story more exciting
a common complaint from Twilight haters
is that the first book has no plot I
feel like this complaint comes from
people who don't understand romance as a
genre it's like that Goodreads review of
Pride and Prejudice just a bunch of
people going to each other's houses
strictly speaking true but this person's
idea of plot is too narrow they think
that plot just means physical action
even Stephanie Meyers seems to think
this to some extent because there's a
lot of what I would consider gratuitous
action forced into these stories the
last movie ends with this giant battle
between the Mormon vampires and their
army of ethnic stereotypes good
missionary work I guess and their sworn
enemies the volui the Italian scum the
Vol are like a Mormons idea of Catholics
you know they live in the Vatican they
speak
Italian they're
gay I do love the V they're my kind of
Vamps I guess it was the 2000s and
everything had to have giant battle
scenes because Lord of the Rings why
can't a romance just be a romance Pride
and Prejudice didn't end with Darcy
hunting down Wickam in a high-speed
Carriage Chase isn't my husband a fine
Horseman romance stories can have action
elements but they're primarily driven by
emotion pining longing yearning even the
plot of a romance is always desire
deferred in her natural history of the
romance novel romance scholar Pamela
reges says quote the barrier is the
conflict in a romance novel it is
anything that keeps the union of heroine
and hero from taking place in Pride and
Prejudice the barrier is in the title
it's Darcy's pride and Elizabeth's
Prejudice and Mrs Bennett certainly
isn't helping either B's wealth is
nothing to his lower your voice woman
everyone can hear you I don't care if he
does in Twilight you may be thinking the
barrier is Jacob hey beautiful because
there are triangular moments between
Jacob Bella and Edward but let's face
the facts Team Jacob never stood a
chance it's always been him the barrier
is really just that Edward wants to
drink that girl's Sweet Blood and who
can blame him I've been thinking about
taking a sip myself in Twilight blood
drinking is a metaphor for sinful Lust
For violent lust Edward's inner conflict
is between lust and love he loves Bella
but he lusts for her blood and because
his blood lust will kill her he has to
resist the temptation of blood lust in
order to love Bella I still don't know
if I can control myself that's the
barrier he overcomes it's an internal
barrier a psychological conflict stop
Find the Will the barrier is essential
to romance stories because narrative is
sustained by tension and so is romantic
love now I should explain that by Roman
itic love I mean what the ancient Greeks
called Aeros Aeros is the ancient Greek
personification of erotic love that
archery twink better known by his Roman
name Cupid and I'm not just bringing
this up to be pretentious though that is
a benefit in English the word love is
awkwardly non-specific you love your
friends you love your husband you love
your dad you love your dog you love God
you love Twizzlers love love love as if
it's all the same Greek has different
words for all these kinds of love
there's filia Brotherly Love Agapi
spiritual love stori familial love filaa
selflove and then there's Aeros the
problem child Aeros is the aching
passionate longing of romance novels of
sapo's poetry of Romeo and Juliet it's
similar to what the psychologist Dorothy
tenof called limerance limerance is like
an adult Crush sexual by Nature
intense to the point of obsession and
anguish Aeros or limerance or romantic
love whatever we want to call it is the
emotional impetus of The Twilight Saga
people who have never experienced
limerance will be confused by Bella's
behavior in Twilight because it's
extreme it's irrational it's obsessive
it's all consuming it's at times
masochistic in New Moon after Edward
breaks up with Bella she shrieks in
agony all through the night
and then sits in her depression chair
staring dejectedly out the window for
three consecutive months there's a
possibility meow meow meow meow meow
meow meow to an a-romantic person this
might look like Madness because it is
madness it's just not normal this
Behavior but to anyone who's been in
love it's your Madness unlike other
forms of Love erotic love is
painful when you left you took
everything with you the absence of him
is everywhere I look the absence of him
is everywhere I look absence is the
essential nature of erotic love because
Aeros is desire and desire is lack you
want what you don't have the essayist
Anne Carson explores this idea in one of
my favorite books Aros the Bittersweet
the title comes from one of saf's poems
Aeros once again limb loosener whirs me
Sweet Bitter impossible to fight off
creature stealing up so why is AOS
bitter well we say that a person in love
is in search of their other half in
Plato's Symposium Aristophanes tells a
myth about the origin of Love which says
that we all used to be double what we
are now round beings with four arms and
two heads and two sets of reproductive
organs until Zeus split us all in half
why is God always an abusive father
concerning so when we fall in love we're
yearning to heal the trauma of human
human nature to be whole again yearning
is always a desire for something we feel
like we have lost and it's that ache of
loss of Separation that makes Aeros
bitter and Carson says quote Pleasure
and Pain at once register upon the lover
in as much as the desirability of the
love object derives in part from its
lack because desire is derived from lack
something has to separate the lover and
the Beloved for desire to sustain itself
in romance fiction that something is the
barrier the ruse an Carson calls it the
third thing that triangulates desire the
purpose of the barrier is quote to
represent arrows as deferred defied
obstructed hungry organized around a
radiant absence to represent AOS as lack
when the barrier is overcome when the
two lovers unite that's the end of your
romance novel because the narrative is
sustained by desire and desire is
sustained by separation so when the
separation ends the desire ends and
that's the end of your story The Lover's
kiss odys is home the end happily ever
after is of course not a reality it's
just a device of romance fiction in
reality when two people in love unite is
what we call a long-term relationship
which I'm sorry if I'm the one breaking
this news to you but many long-term
relationships are not in fact happily
ever after it's not easy to sustain
desire over years you have to keep
inventing new rues new barriers that
create the space for desire to
continuously reite successful couples
either learn to be content with a more
pragmatic non-erotic love or they're
somehow able to sustain AOS falling in
love with each other again and again but
I fear that's the exception the rule is
absence makes the heart grow fonder
another way to put this would be to say
that desire prefers the hunt to the kill
and maybe that's one reason sexuality is
often represented as predator and prey
the first shot of the first Twilight
movie is of a deer being stalked by a
predator this tells us what kind of
story it's going to be so the lion fell
in love with the lamb Edward the lion
Cullen embodies Hunter sexuality he
glares he stalks he pounces and Bella at
least at first is his prey what a stupid
Li a similar Trope of lover as Hunter
exists on Ancient Greek earns which
often depict a lover not in possession
but in pursuit of his beloved and Carson
says quote the moment of Ideal desire on
which vay painters as well as poets are
inclined to focus is not the moment when
the two unite in happiness what is
pictured is the moment when the Beloved
turns and runs it's the moment of
obstructed desire John Keats described
in his ode on a Grecian earn bold lover
never never can that thou kiss the
winning near the goal yet do not grieve
she cannot fade though thou Hast not thy
Bliss forever wil thou love and she be
fair the poet or the ear painter
captures that moment of desire for all
time the Hunter suspended in the middle
of a hunt desire is like a dog that
wants to chase a squirrel but not to
catch it and it may be this fugitive
element of Desire that gives rise to
double standards where the Beloved the
one who is pursued is valued only as
long as she is unattainable to quote an
Carson again cuz I love her so much a
titilating triangle comes into play
between the lover the bad girl who
attracts him and the good girl who
honors him by saying no in this kind of
dating ritual the barrier is the good
girl who is modest elusive hard to get
like in the 9s there was this Infamous
dating manual for women called the rules
time test secrets for capturing the
heart of Mr wri it included such advice
as always end phone calls first don't
accept a Saturday night date after
Wednesday in other words play hard to
get the rules strikes many people as
oppressively old-fashioned at best and
straight up Psychopathic at worst and I
agree I don't think the rules should be
taken too seriously but there is a
little grain of Truth in it Simone
deovir says the night departing for new
adventure ures offends his lady yet she
has nothing but contempt for him if he
remains at her feet this is the torture
of impossible love to paraphrase the
psychoanalyst jacqu laon desire thinks
it wants to be satisfied but really it
wants to go on Desiring desire is desire
for desire Shakespeare says something
similar in Sonet 147 my love is as a
fever longing still for that which
longer nurseth the disease Shakespeare
Compares desire that is love Aeros to a
sickness that wants to perpetuate itself
what doesn't kill me makes me want you
more is Taylor Swift's version of the
same thought and a song that begins
fever dream high in the quiet of the
night echoing Shakespeare's comparison
of love to a fever a desire that feeds
on its own frustration and I'm pretty
sure Taylor agrees with what I'm saying
in this video also I apologize for
criticizing her in my JK rolling video
I've since read a bunch of Tumblr posts
that convince me that she's gay
inspiring follow the money in an episode
of Seinfeld George castanza makes a
distinction between two types of Desire
yearning and craving do you ever yearn
yearn do I yearn have you yearned well
not recently I craved I crave all the
time constant craving I haven't yearned
what is the difference between yearning
and craving well let's start with
craving what kinds of things do you
crave you crave a cigarette a sandwich
an orgasm a drink you satisfy a craving
for something but then an hour later you
crave it again so maybe craving is a
desire that can be satisfied but only
for a moment craving is like
Shakespeare's description of lust and
Sonet 129 the expensive spirit in a
waste of Shame is lust in action enjoyed
no sooner but despised straight a bliss
in proof and proved a very woe before a
joy proposed behind a dream a poor baby
bill was really having a hard time in
those sonnets how is yearning different
from craving well maybe it's the
difference between love and lust the
difference between Shakespeare's Sonet
129 and 147 craving is enjoyed no sooner
but despised straight and yearning is a
fever longing still for that which
longer nurseth the disease isn't this
what Stephanie Meers really trying to
say here Edward Cullen craves blood but
he yearns for Bella it's lust against
limerance let's talk about yearning do
you ever yearn what kinds of things do
you yearn for you yearn for Union with a
person you're in love with or for Union
with God like in Psalm 63 my whole being
Longs for you in a dry and parched land
where there is no water you yearn for
God you don't crave God no one says I
need to get my God fixed don't talk to
me until I've had my God you yearn to
feel whole again maybe by finding your
other half or through some kind of
shroomy Oneness or maybe Freud was right
that it's really mother who we yearn for
mother I mean we did use to be one with
her body in the womb and then they cut
the umbilical cord and they weaned you
from her breast and life has been
downhill ever
since yearning maybe you yearn for the
good old days Nostalgia a yearning for
lost time or you yearn for Nostalgia
inverse utopian socialism think about
the kind of leftists who talk about the
revolution like it's the Rapture these
people are yearning for a different time
but it's one they imagine in the future
yearning I think is inherently erotic
it's not necessarily sexual but it's
erotic in the sense that unlike craving
which can be satisfied though only for a
moment yearning is a desire that can't
really be satisfied at all like you know
how no matter what you accomplish in
life you can never really be satisfied
because you always still feel the same
void inside eating away at you all the
time well this is the reason for that we
all have a black hole deep inside of us
and nothing can ever really fill it some
people call it a god-shaped hole but I'm
pretty sure my god-shaped hole is shaped
like actually I think the hole is
flexible it kind of shapes itself to
whatever it is we think we're missing
the things we desire become symbols of
the whole and we come to believe that
we're yearning for this symbol an Carson
says quote who is the real subject of
most love poems not the Beloved it is
that whole now would be a good time to
admire my restraint and not making any
jokes about filling my holes very
tasteful very ladylike I know you may
praise me in the comments section now
Lon says something similar I'll quote
xi's summary because Lan is illegible if
you don't care about philosophy just
ignore these names close your eyes and
pretend this isn't happening quote the
drive's goal to reach its object is
false it masks its true aim which is to
reproduce its own circular Movement by
repeatedly missing its object
this is the Trap of Yearning of
unrequited love and of nostalgia you
yearn for the good old days because you
lack them they are lost time but try
explaining that to the people in the
comments section of a '90s Fruity
Pebbles commercial pining for the last
golden age I miss the world when there
was still love left in it yumy
pees on second thought the Fruity
Pebbles commercial may be the only thing
holding this man's sanity together let's
just let him have this I wish there was
a way to know you're in the good old
days before you've actually left them we
all wish there was a way to feel like
you're in the good old days but there
isn't it's impossible why well you're
never in the good old days because you
can only yearn for what you've lost the
good old days are old because they're
gone and they're good because you
idealize what you yearn for and you only
yearn for what you do not have your
childhood is is dead and no amount of
Fruity Pebbles will bring it back I've
[Music]
tried advertising simulates Desire by
invoking lack often yearning for beauty
Prestige and glamour glamour simply is
the unattainable the always Out Of Reach
do you ever feel like Goldilocks in a
world where the porridge is never just
right I feel like I'm describing some
kind of pessimist's prayer you can't get
what you want and if you do it won't
make you happy and if it does not for
long the only way to escape the cycle of
suffering the only path to Salvation is
to both like And subscribe give me your
money you know I think I crave because I
yearn suppose hypothetically someone
named I don't know Veronica is an unre
love and suppose the pain of that drives
Veronica hypothetically for educational
and harm reduction purposes to get a
little bit addicted
to she's craving to cope with the
yearning I like my own personal brand of
heroin what's your favorite brand of
heroin leave a comment maybe you could
visualize Cravings as like epicycles of
the larger cycle of Yearning that orbits
around the void constant craving I
promise this is about Twilight yearning
is Bittersweet and the bitterness of
Yearning comes from the absence at its
core from the futility of grasping at
something always Out Of Reach the
absence of him is everywhere I look but
what about the sweetness the sweetness
of Yearning comes from
antici it's not easy having a good time
the sweetness of Yearning comes from
anticipation it's the hope that just
maybe you might finally grasp the thing
you're reaching for this time there's a
German word for this because of course
for frea which means preasure the
pleasure of anticipation is the reason
that we gift wrap presents as Ted Bundy
said the fantasy that accompanies and
generates the anticipation that precedes
the crime is always more stimulating
than the immediate aftermath of the
crime itself so true anticipation is the
basic pleasure of eroticism and I do
think that if you skip right ahead to
sex in a story you're missing out on a
lot of really exciting things the first
time you hold somebody's hand your heart
just goes crazy it's this amazing
experience you go home and tell your
friends about oh my gosh he touched my
hand you know a strip teas is infinitely
more erotic than a nudist colony why
anticipation tension and release the
point of strip teas is that the audience
wants to see a naked woman but once the
woman is naked once the barrier is
removed the show is over Stripes is like
the visual equivalent of a slow build
romance novel aren't mystery stories
like this too are Mysteries erotic the
pleasure is in unraveling the mystery
the yearning for the truth the
anticipation of the answer once the
puzzle is solved you lose interest this
is how people become conspiracy
theorists they get addicted to that Rush
of Discovery going down the rabbit hole
is the pursuit of Truth rather than the
possession of it a better outlet for
this urge is philosophy philosophy is
inherently erotic in that philosophical
questions by Nature can never be
definitively answered so the epistemic
yearning never ends in The Importance of
Being Earnest algae says the very
essence of romance is uncertainty
uncertainty is also the very essence of
gambling it's why I wasted $2,000
playing Egypt Quest gambling is
addictive because the for frea the
anticipation of maybe win is more
compelling than the win itself very
romantic to be in love but there's
nothing romantic about a definite
proposal one may be accepted one usually
is I believe then the whole excitement
is over uncertainty sustains the
Bittersweet mix of Hope and anxiety
which is ruinous when it leads to the
junky behavior of gambling addicts and
serial adultery but which I think can be
safely simulated in art consider
Twilight to choose a random example will
this romance end in love or murder it
doesn't matter if you know it will end
with a happily ever after it's about the
process how you get there consider the
music of my youth Mozart this Symphony
number 25 in G minor guess what chord it
ends on spoiler alert G minor people
think Mozart is stuffy now but it's very
erotic music it's all about tension and
release Mozart builds tension through
devices like Rising Melody increased
dissonance increased voice volume
rhythmic complexity harmonic wandering
from the tonic or simply adding more
notes too many notes the tension is
released in a chord sequence called a
Cadence music teachers always describe
the Cadence as returning home comparing
the musical narrative structure to a
hero's journey on its own the Cadence is
kind of boring so it's often drawn out
and ornamented with a
Trill what is the point of this gesture
well it heightens the tension just as
it's about to be
[Music]
released the trill occurs at that pre
climactic moment when gratification is
imminent it's very sexual it's musical
edging when you hear it in isolation it
just sounds like an 18th century musical
stock phrase but that's exactly the
point I'm making the release is only
pleasurable because of the tension that
is accumulated in anticipation of it
without the tension there is no release
and that's just kind of the nature of
human pleasure it's Fire and Ice here
doctor father says we are so constituted
that we can only intensely enjoy
contrasts without the bitterness of
tension there is no sweetness of release
philosophies that seek to liberate us
from suffering ad
that we let go of Desire stoicism says
we should limit desire to things we can
control Buddhism says we can stop
craving and clinging by recognizing that
desire arises from impermanence and from
the illusion of the self philosophers
and gurus are correct to recognize that
desire leads to
suffering but Detachment From Desire is
not Bliss if someone is promising you
Bliss or some mystical solution to the
wound of human nature that's probably a
cult watch out for that Detachment
results in something more lowkey like
Tranquility or peace wise men are always
saying stop clinging to desire and
you'll find peace wise men are always
saying this the daed Jing chapter 46
says one who knows that enough is enough
will always have enough that is wisdom
and wisdom is soothing but it's not
exciting so it's really your choice to
make do you want to read novels about
wise people being at peace or do you
choose violence do you choose the
world's most dangerous predator
personally I think wisdom is best left
to the wise couldn't be me I like things
and stuff too much the wheel of samsara
is very much my stomping ground
[Music]
so in Maryland there's this place called
Royal
Farms it's like if a KFC was inside of a
7-Eleven they're open all the time you
get
cigarettes chicken energy drinks you
know human blood part three
fantasy okay we need to talk about the
sexual aspect I know YouTube is trying
to be more family friendly and as a
friend of the family I respect that so I
might have to use some euphemisms some
indirect Language by the time I'm done
with them the family is going to be on
their hands and knees begging for more
many people have commented on the
unguarded blurting it all out quality of
Twilight in one interview Robert patson
said he thinks that Twilight is
Stephanie Meyer's sexual fantasy I was
convinced that Stephanie was con
convinced she was Bella and you're like
reading her her sort of sexual fantasy
about some and especially when she says
it was based on a dream I think this is
another reason that people find Twilight
cringe Stephanie Meyer is taking
dictation directly from the inner
goddess and it's very honest it's really
really honest and that's kind of what's
weird about it I love that about
Twilight it's like reading someone's
diary now I realize here I'm stepping
into a vicious debate that's been going
on for decades about the difference
between romance and erotica what is the
difference between romance and erotica I
got so curious about this that I
actually contacted the English
departments of Harvard Yale and Stanford
and I was surprised that they pretty
much all agreed on a definition that
romance is for good girls and erotica is
for slots pornography of course is for
men there's a buck wild debate from 1987
between romance Titans Jackie Collins
and Barbara Cartland who between them
sold more than a billion books the
debate gets well you kind of just have
to see it to believe it it's evil really
Weck the books that you write quite
frankly Barbara Cartland says that
Jackie Collins books are evil why
because they have sex scenes well I
really don't think there's anything
disgusting about naked people rolling
around on beds I thought that's what
you're supposed to do when you're
married how do you know and according to
Cartland women's fiction shouldn't have
sex scenes because a think of the
children have you ever thought it has on
young people yes they love it and they
WR I was reading it under two is helping
the perverts don't you think it has
helped the purpose it has and D
according to Cartland we should
encourage Purity for women that is
asexuality you know I believe in Purity
for women and this is the thing I've
been fighting for it's a classic good
girls versus debate all this awful
abusive children all that comes from
permissive s there's something so
surreal about what I can only describe
as an 80-year-old woman in clown drag
lecturing everyone about sexual Purity
like what is this the British aren't
coming the British aren't coming Carland
endorses the Victorian Viewpoint that
women ladies are asexual you were a lady
you were dressed in China you were
something perfect slightly sacred this
is a view taken by 19th century
sexologist Richard Fon craft ebbing
author of psychopathia sexualis one of
the first attempts to scientifically
study human sexuality So Scandalous at
the time of publication that it had to
be printed in Latin to keep the Hoy pooy
from getting Notions quote woman if
physically and mentally normal and
properly educated has but little sensual
desire this is an absurd claim on its
face if women instinctually have but
little sensual desire then why is that
contingent on their being properly
educated the answer is basically that
for victorians the Madonna
dichotomy was an ontological distinction
there was an enormous gap between the
lady and The Prostitute and no young man
who took me out would ever have thought
of asking me to go to bed with him they
asked me to marry him it was understood
that there were really two very
different kinds of women there were real
women ladies who were by definition
asexual and then there was this other
category of person prostitutes or Fallen
women who were technically female but
who were seen as degraded ruined beings
with desire equal to if not exceeding
that of men strumpets trollops slous
ladies were seen as delicate and
innocent sacred Treasures to be
protected you were a lady you were
dressed in China you were something
perfect slightly sacred and there's a
kind of privilege that came with that
but at the cost of sexuality and I
believed it for years I thought that
ladies didn't feel P feel passion and
prostitutes did Lady status has often
only been available to middle and upper
class white women with prostitutes and
Fallen women relegated to this other
category that was seen as sexual but
degraded the idea that Purity is the
natural state of women is actually
fairly recent ancient and medieval
Europeans had almost the opposite view
of the victorians often seeing women as
more sexual than men according to the
most widely read Encyclopedia of the
Middle Ages quote the word femina comes
from the Greek derived from the force of
fire because her concupiscence is very
passionate women are more libidinous
than men in an ancient Greek myth Zeus
and Hera are feuding about whether men
or women enjoy sex more so they summon
the transsexual Prophet tyresius to
resolve the issue and tyresius says of
10 parts a man enjoys one only but a
woman enjoys the full 10 parts which sex
is more sexual controversial looking
into it in our own time the Victorian
idea that the right kind of women have
but little sensual desire still persists
in stereotypes about female sexuality
being limited to delicate hand
grazing in
1973 permissive Cosmopolitan magazine
ran an article by a male psychiatrist
who announced women do not have sexual
fantasies how do we know ask a woman and
she will usually reply no good work
doctor incredible research methods this
kind of statement is a self-fulfilling
prophecy when the experts announced that
women do not have sexual fantasies women
whose experience tells them other wise
feel deviant and abnormal which makes
them reluctant to speak up seemingly
descriptive statements about sexuality
like women do not have sexual fantasies
often serve to enforce the very
situation they claim to describe the
Cartland Collins debate was echoed 25
years later in debates about Twilight
and 50 Shades of Gray with 50 Shades
widely condemned as mommy porn which
come on people let moms have pornography
it's like once a decade Society
collectively discovers that women's
sexuality exists and everyone loses
their minds Stephany Meyer like Barbara
Cartland is something of a Neo Victorian
or at least a Neo Edwardian boo
Stephanie is not as moralizing as
Barbara Cartland but she has said for
example erotica is not something I read
I don't even read traditional romance
why not it's too smutty there's a reason
my books have a lot of Innocence that's
the sort of world I live in well I
support what Stephanie Meyer has to tell
herself to sleep at night I don't know
that I would describe Twilight as a
world of Innocence I've killed people
before I like watching you sleep it's
hard to say with all those clothes on
stranger things happen every day trust
me but it's true that there are no sex
scenes it's strictly PG-13 in one scene
Bella is too embarrassed to look at
lingerie because it's too sexy even when
it isn't on in an now Infamous scene
Bella walks down the stairs and a long
khaki skirt and blue blouse which outfit
Edward describes as utterly indecent no
one should look so tempting it's not
fair so what did Robert patson mean when
he said that Twilight is Stephanie
Meyer's sexual fantasy you're like
reading her her sort of sexual fantasy a
story can be sexy without sex scenes how
well I feel like this is something that
I should show and not tell for example
can we talk about the tent scene
why is no one talking talking about the
cuck tent scene in Twilight Episode 3
Eclipse Bella and her polycule of
monster men are taking the ring to
Mordor when a winter storm rolls in
Bella is in the tent and she's shivering
her innocent little butt off and
Edward's upset because vampires have no
body heat so he can't warm her up but
Jacob is right outside and Jacob is a
toasty dog boy with a canonical body
temperature of 108.9 De F let's face it
I am hotter than you so Edward agrees to
let the sexy shirtless Jacob share a
sleeping bag with Bella to prevent her
imminent death by freezing you'll warm
up soon faster if you took your clothes
off Jacob clutches Bella against his hot
naked chest while Edward gazes on in
jealous Agony Bella is nestled in
Jacob's arms pretending to be asleep
while the two gorgeous monster men are
incandescent with desire for her they
argue through the night about who loves
her more and who can take better care of
her and remember Edward can read minds
so he's experiencing all of Jacob's
perverted fantasies in excruciating
detail can you at least attempt to
control your thoughts so why does this
scene happen wherefore art the tent
this is not a trick question the answer
is very obvious the tent happens
because Stephanie Meyer thinks it's hot
because it is hot and maybe Stephanie
would deny that she has any such impure
feelings since she lives in a world of
innoc Ence but let's use common sense
this is a sexual fantasy almost
everything that went into Twilight was
unconscious a lot of women like to feel
intensely desired it's why a common
feminine fantasy is being at the center
of attention from multiple men because
more men symbolizes more desire it's why
you get romance novels like two
billionaires in Vegas three boss's
assistant four ranchers bride five Mafia
captors virgin six single dads Nanny
seven groomsmen from hell eight brothers
fiance nine Marines shared property 10
Mountain men's baby and weing Heights
it's a really straightforward example of
what is called wish fulfillment and
Twilight has a lot of wish fulfillment
you know Bella moves to a new school and
even though she's an awkward tomboy who
drives a rusty pickup truck every boy in
school has a crush on her it's like
first grade all over again you're the
shiny new toy two gorgeous monster boys
fight over Bella and they carry her
around and they tell her how much they
love her and want to protect her all the
other girls are jealous of my cool
boyfriend so by association I must be
cool too if you're a Twilight reader and
you identify with Bella these are
exciting fantasies to have because they
gratify what Dr father calls his majesty
the ego the hero of everyday dream and
every story all of this I think is
pretty obvious but where things get
controversial and to many people
disturbing is when you start start
introducing darker themes into your
romantic wish fulfillment fantasies
Edward stalking I like watching you
sleep the fact that he's self-
admittedly a dangerous predator I'm the
world's most dangerous predat his
struggle with a vampiric desire to kill
Bella and drink her blood people see
this stuff and they think oh my God this
is masochistic it's internalized
misogyny it's abusive it's pathological
but I think that those concerns while
understandable come from a
misunderstanding of how fantasy Works
consider for example the ultimate
problematic fantasy the fantasy of
non-consent what we could
euphemistically call a ravishment
fantasy this fantasy of being
overpowered or in bondage or
surrendering to a dominant lover it's a
very common fantasy for a lot of women
and also a lot of people who aren't
women it's the reason bodice rippers are
called bodice rippers they were
notorious for these ravishment scenes
where bodices are you know
and this can be difficult to talk about
because you know we worry that the worst
men in the universe will take these
fantasies as proof that women really
want to be dominated by Violent Men but
abusive men will use any pretext to
justify their behavior and that's not on
us it's on them so let's talk about it
in 1973 the same year that Cosmo
announced women don't have sexual
fantasies the author Nancy Friday
published a book called my secret Garden
women's sexual fantasies Nancy Friday
was a heroine of the sexual Revolution
and I think it was Brave of her to
publish this book despite its
misleadingly twe cover and blurb dare to
discover the beautiful blossoms the
winding paths and the hidden Nooks of
female sexuality I hate that even the
cover of a pervert book like this
assumes that female sexuality is as
mysterious as it is floral
groundbreaking but there's nothing
floral about the contents of Nancy
Friday's books which are essentially
anthologies of fantasies submitted in
response to a newspaper ad Nancy
published that said female sexual
fantasies wanted by serious female
researcher anonymity guaranteed love
that this resulted in a book which is
very explicit and which challenges
assumptions about feminine sexuality
being sort of soft and gentle and mushy
the single greatest theme that emerged
was that of weak women being sexually
dominated forced by male strength to do
this deliciously awful thing so the
ravishment fantasy proved to be the most
common
fantasy why are these women all horribly
traumatized is this internalized
misogyny well maybe but there's other
explanations to consider you know women
are kind of socialized not to display
sexuality openly not to initiate being a
proper feminine woman is supposed to
involve being passive and modest or else
women risk being recast from Madonna to
good girl to and being
victimized and degraded as a result so
it makes sense that a lot of women might
be very protective of their innocent
good girl self-image even in fantasy the
non-consent fantasy is a device that
absolves the woman from blame if she's
being forced then it's not her fault
ravishment is a ruse as Nancy Friday
says quote a deas exmachina we roll into
to catapult us past a lifetime of
women's rules against sex the women whom
I've interviewed don't really want to be
hurt or humiliated his male presence
that effective battering ram neatly
makes her relax sufficiently to enjoy
and then allows her to return to Earth
her nice girl good daughter self- intact
so the non consent fantasy is not wish
fulfillment in a literal sense but in an
emotional sense like if a teenage boy
fantasizes about dying gloriously in
battle is that a masochistic fantasy
about death or is it an egotistical
fantasy about Glory probably the latter
likewise women who fantasize about being
ravished do not actually want to be
assaulted in a fantasy which is a
fictional scenario where you are in
control the non sense situation
satisfies your emotional needs to
gratify desire without the burden of
Shame and guilt and anxiety that comes
with taking responsibility for your
desire another vampire novelist an rice
said of her own pom masochistic erotica
series The Books aren't about literal
cruelty they're about surrender the fun
of imagining you have no choice but to
enjoy sex the essential point is this
fantasies are not literal wishes
fantasies construct situations where
emotional needs are met and inhibitions
to pleasure are removed so for example
in a fantasy where the dangerous alpha
male is the aggressor the woman remains
innocent the bad boy is bad so that the
good girl gets to stay good we could
call this disavowal the process of
constructing fantasy situations where
your desires are gratified without
having to assert or even having to
acknowledge the desire non-consent
fantasies are one ruse of disavowal but
fantasy is infinitely creative in
constructing these devices remember the
tent Bella is a good girl who would
never consider having a threesome but
it's dangerously cold I guess we have no
choice but to huddle for warmth
disavowal me and Draco got detention in
the Forbidden Forest and we had to camp
out for the night but there was only one
sleeping bag guess we have to share it
there's a million fanfiction and erotica
tropes that are basically variations on
this ruse of disavowal for example sex
pollen aliens made them do it hypnosis
mind control non-consent dubious consent
mat or die Pon far forced feminization
Hermione is an Omega in heat and Draco
is the only nearby Alpha the continued
popularity of these tropes demonstrates
to me that erotic disavow fantasies are
not just a relic of a past age of bodice
Rippers and sexual conservatism I don't
think that women today are much more
liberated than Nancy Friday and Anne
Rice like where are these liberated
women maybe in Europe look I don't know
what goes on over there in peros slavia
but here in America we still believe in
a little thing called sexual repression
like if you look through fanfiction
platforms like watpad and A3 that host
erotica mostly by women submissive
fantasies are still pretty standard my
mom sold my virginity to One Direction I
also see disavow at work in the infamous
rescue fantasies in Twilight Bella is
walking the street alone at night when
she's menaced by a gang of thugs
apparently ready for a bit of the old
Ultraviolence but at the last minute
Edward sweeps in in his battle Volvo and
saves the damel likewise at the end of
the first movie there's a um a snuff f
film scene where the evil vampire James
intends to suck Bella's blood and make
some kind of smut film out of it to
torture Edward with this very eroticized
violence is interrupted at the last
moment when Edward replaces the asent
and Bella is rescued instead of ravished
you try to suck the venom out no I won't
be able to stop find the
wheel I see this as a kind of double
disavowal it's a non-consent fantasy
that's transformed into something more
morally acceptable a rescue fantasy
rescued damils are a common erotic myth
in the story of Perseus and Andromeda
Andromeda is a naked woman in bondage
threatened by a monster but saved at the
last minute by pereus thrusting into the
rescue with some kind of phallic weapon
in rescue fantasies the thrilling
possibility of sexual violence is raised
only to be disavowed at the last minute
by the rescue but it's not just women
who disavow desire the rescue fantasy is
also appealing from the perspective of
pereus who gets to feel strong and
important and heroic while also you know
getting to spend time around a naked
woman in
Chains It's not even necessarily sexual
desire that fantasy disavows in 50
Shades of Gray Edward renamed Christian
is constantly issuing orderers to bellaa
renamed Anastasia about what she should
eat what car she should drive about what
what gynecologist to see why is this
part of the fantasy well because making
decisions is hard s said we're condemned
to be free why is freedom a condemnation
well because Freedom implies
responsibility and responsibility sucks
I for one hate being accountable for the
consequences of my actions even
something as trivial as what should I
eat today is a decision fraught with
moral quandries and Body Image issues
isues and contradictory nutritional
advice coming at us from all angles
isn't there something relaxing about a
competent person just telling you what
to do so you don't have to worry about
it disavow is a useful ruse for
indulging in all kinds of guilty
pleasures in 50 Shades Christian is
constantly lavishing extravagant gifts
on Anna he buys her a computer a car
first class plane tickets and Anna
constantly protests because she knows
that it's goh to accept expensive gifts
from your billionaire boyfriend like
some kind of kept woman but Christian
insists oh well I guess I have no choice
but to fly first class the function of
disavowal in Fantasy is that you get
what you want without the indignity of
having to ask for it or even against
your will in Twilight Bella hates
birthday parties and presents but
they're lavished on her anyway Edward's
fashionista sister Alice is always
feminizing Bella ordering her to wear
high heels and Bella's like no stop I
wear flannel and drive pickup trucks I'm
totally butch but clearly she's into
this forested feminization this debing
Bella is adamant she doesn't want to
fancy wedding but Alice insists so
there's a fancy wedding obviously
Stephanie wanted there to be a fancy
wedding but you know what people say
about women who want fancy weddings
Divas Bridezillas not a cute look so
thanks to Alice Bella gets to have a
fancy wedding without the indignity of
having to want a fancy wedding now I
want to talk about one of the most
controversial things that happens in
Twilight Jacob imprinting on reneesme
okay so I can't wait to explain this one
Stephanie introduces into werewolf lore
the notion of imprinting a kind of
lifelong liant fixation it's soulmates
basically in Breaking Dawn Bella gives
birth to a vampiric baby whom she names
reneesme yes it's very funny let's all
laugh to Bella essentially dies in
childbirth and before she's resurrected
Jacob decides to murder reneesme the
baby as revenge for killing Bella but
when Jacob sees reneesme he imprints on
her the baby essentially falling in love
with this infant now I think this is
amazing but everyone else seems seems to
hate it you imprinted on my daughter it
wasn't my choice she's a baby why would
Stephanie write such a thing I think
Jacob imprints on reneesme because
Stephanie is unconsciously both Team
Edward and Team Jacob almost everything
that went into Twilight was unconscious
I mean it's not that subtle you can love
more than one person at a time don't
make me choose but obviously Bella can't
be polyamorous because Stephanie's books
have a lot of Innocence that's the sort
of world she lives in so imprinting on
reneesme allows Bella to secure
monogamous ties to both Edward through
marriage and to Jacob vicariously
through her own daughter thus roping
Jacob into this subtextually polyamorous
family we're all going to be together
now so should I start calling you
[Music]
Dad no I'm not saying you have to like
it I'm just saying that's why this
happens probably so I've been arguing
that a lot of fantasies work by
constructing situations where your
desires are both fulfilled and disavowed
but there's more to it than just that if
we consider the more problematic aspects
of Twilight Edward's stalking his
violent urges the ravishment turned
rescue fantasies the appeal is not just
that it absolves the Bella identified
reader of the responsibility and
stigma of sexuality there's also
something about the intensity and even
the violence of a fantasy Lover's desire
that is exciting there's a book by the
psychoanalyst Michael Bader called
arousal the secret logic of sexual
fantasies that I really enjoyed which
surprised me because I found it in the
psychology section between why is my
marriage bad and help my teenager is a
piece of Bader's book takes a very
optimistic view of sexual fantasy quote
I do not think sexuality is driven by
kinky desires I think that it is driven
by straightforward desires for pleasure
and safety kinkiness is merely the
complicated route that some people need
to take in order to safely feel pleasure
according to Bader fantasy is a tool for
overcoming guilt shame anxiety
responsibility and other obstacles to
pleasure and arousal like Freud said the
sexual Instinct has to struggle against
certain mental forces which act as
resistances dam upon sexual development
disgust shame and morality fantasy
functions to break through the dam to
rip the metaphorical bodice in the
Cinderella fantasy where a billionaire
Falls for you an ordinary brunette the
attention of this powerful man functions
as a proof of your worth of your
desirability it's fundamentally a shame
negating fantasy it's satisfying because
most people have shame have insecurities
we feel too old too fat too trans too
disabled it's always something right or
maybe you were neglected as a child or
your sibling was always more beautiful
and successful than you or you feel
underappreciated at work or your YouTube
videos don't get as many views as H
bomber guy whatever the source of the
insecurity this shame is a damn an
inhibition an obstacle to pleasure it's
hard to get excited when you feel
inadequate unattracted active or
ordinary but in the eyes of this fantasy
billionaire or Vampire who's obsessed
with you you become extraordinary the
fantasy creates a situation where your
insecurities are proven false or in
which your flaws turn out to be
desirable which negates the shame that
inhibits pleasure a feminist objection
to 50 Shades might go why does it have
to be a rich husband why can't women
fantasize about financial Independence
well because that completely
misunderstands the emotional logic of
the fantasy it's not really about the
money money is just an efficient symbol
it signifies value worth in the logic of
fantasy a rich man is a high value man
especially to us a vulgar Americans to
an Old-Fashioned English woman like
Barbara Cartland the ideal romantic hero
is preferably a peer of the realm a
disgraceful Duke a wicked Marquee an
elusive Earl in desperate times we might
even settle for a cruel count when his
lordship bestows upon you lavish gifts
despite your protests and disavowals the
gifts are proof that he desires you that
you are as enticing as any beautiful
expensive object the wealth and gifts
are of secondary importance first we
seek the refutation of our shame the
validation of our desirability and above
all proof that we are loved often this
type of fantasy involves a competitive
element too where Rivals usually other
women must be eliminated this is taken
to embarrassing Extremes in 50 Shades of
Gray where Christian surrounds himself
with what Anna refers to as Immaculate
blondes and Stepford Wives young blonde
women whom Christian employs precisely
because he's not attracted to any of
them Christian only being attracted to
superficially ordinary and awkward
brunettes who remind him of and this is
a direct quotation the crack wh my birth
mother
y Anna also has the satisfaction of
humiliating the attractive blonde
architect Christian hires to design
their house and at one point she throws
a drink in the face of Christian's
childhood seductress who yes is also
blonde he's not capable of
marriage in Twilight Bella is a
superficially ordin AR and awkward
brunette who is frequently jealous of
Edward's blonde bombshell sister Rosalie
as well as the Denali Cen of vampires
blonde vix andzel to whom we are assured
Edward feels not the slightest twinge of
Attraction my point is that this need
and fantasy to cancel out every other
attractive woman has the same meaning
Anna Freud attributed to a female
patient's fantasy father loves only me
and the fact that the men in these
fantasies are often substitute father
figures is a fact so obvious that it
hardly warrants mentioning I know I look
hot feminine sexual fantasies are often
modeled on myths and fairy tales
Cinderella sleeping beauty Beauty and
the Beast Little Red Riding Hood Hades
and pany Adam and Eve pereus and
Andromeda if Cinderella style fantasies
are usually about refuting shame I'd
argue that Beauty and the Beast style
fantasies are usually about negating
guilt by Beauty and the Beast style
fantasies I mean erotic fantasies where
the hero is a Mafia Boss a stalker a
pirate an abusive employer a conduct
violating Professor a disgraceful Duke a
sadistic billionaire or for that matter
my own brother a godamn sucking
vampire my own brother a godamn
sucking vampire obviously in Twilight
as in a lot of romance fiction the hero
is both Prince Charming and the Beast a
Darcy with Heathcliff characteristics
what is the fantasy appeal of the
Beast why is he's so sexy well there's
an element of selfishness inherent to
sexuality what Michael Bader calls
ruthlessness quote sexual excitement
requires that we momentarily become
selfish and turn away from concern
conerns about the other's pleasure in
order to surrender to our own women in
particular often feel guilty about being
selfish they're afraid they'll take too
long or that receiving pleasure is
one-sided maybe it's because women are
told to be caretakers to put other
people's needs before their own but in
the fantasy where you've been tied up by
Christian Gray you have no say in the
matter you cannot be guilty because it's
not your fault and the selfishness of of
the Beast gives Beauty permission to be
selfish too to surrender to her own
pleasure Bader says quote sexual
fantasies always find a way of turning
the no of guilt into the yes of pleasure
a similar guilt negation is achieved by
fantasies of anonymity a masked stranger
someone you have no obligation to take
care of and because you're strangers to
each other you also have less reason to
be ashamed it's why when you have an
orgy at your opulent Mansion you have to
make everyone wear a mask like anonymity
opulence is a defense against shame when
someone surrounds thems with opulence
what are they trying to say abouts the
subliminal message of opulence is I am
valuable I am desirable it's why so many
romantic and erotic fantasies take place
in opulent settings now in reality the
ruthlessness enabled by fantasy
eventually conflicts with our desire to
be loved a paradox of sexuality is that
ruthlessness must somehow be balanced
with tenderness if you only use and
objectify your partner there can be no
love but if you're overly anxious about
your partner's needs to the exclusion of
your own the flame of Desire will go out
in sex there is such a thing as not
enough selfishness this is my theory
about the gentle Rogue he's appealing
because he's both gentle and and a rogue
I am very smart the gentle Rogue is a
sort of vegetarian vampire capable of
both ruthlessness and tenderness so from
the perspective of Nancy Friday and
Michael Bader sexual fantasies even ones
that seem violent and disturbing can be
understood as psychological devices that
lead us to pleasure through the
Labyrinth of guilt and shame I wish that
people who are inclined to Crusade
against dangerous books were abuse
abusive ships would try to think about
fantasy in a way that's less literal and
more psychological like do Furies and
Omega verse fic writers normalize
beastiality no the fantasy of human
animality is not about literal animals
it's about unleashing what is
symbolically animalistic in us the
drives and urges that human taboos and
decency forbid people think furries are
weird now but your grandfather fought in
World War II then came home and thought
it was totally normal to be attracted to
women dressed like rabbits are people
who are into Daddy Doms or diapers or
whatever literally normalizing
Pediatrics well no it's usually not
about that at all AG play is usually
about fantasy regression to the social
position of someone who has no
responsibilities and needs to be taken
care of the fantasy or the rle play
scenario gives you permission to be
taken care of Edward Cullen's notorious
I like to watch you sleep I like
watching you sleep feels creepy to a lot
of people and fair enough creepiness is
subjective but I feel like you can find
Edward creepy and still understand that
for Stephanie Meyer Twilight is not an
expression of a literal desire to be
stalked by creatures of the night the
fantasy is of a protector watching ing
over you a witness a guardian angel like
when you're a kid and you want your mom
to stay in your room with you until you
fall asleep I wish that I could fall
asleep with a Vampire watching over me
talking to me and she's saying baby
mommy loves you you're a good baby I
don't blame you for what happened to
this family you're just a baby you had
nothing to do with 9/11 in 2015 radical
feminist Dr Gail dyes the quote world's
leading anti-pornography scholar and
activist according to her website l a
boycott of 50 Shades of Gray using the
hashtag $50 not 50 Shades encouraging
people to donate to battered women's
shelters instead of seeing the movie D
claimed 50 Shades glamorized and
eroticized violence against women and
rebranded it as romance she describes
going to see the movie in a theater full
of young women drinking cocktails and
watching an abject horror quote a film
that depicted in unbearable detail How
to lure a lonely isolated child into
consenting to sexual abuse watching a
seasoned Predator toy with his immature
prey you are left with a knot in the pit
of your stomach that won't go away no
matter how many cocktails you down Gail
it's Twilight fanfiction when I watch 50
Shades I don't feel like I'm watching a
seasoned predator
I feel like I'm watching a woman's
fantasy because I am and if people like
Gil Dian are too obtuse to notice the
difference that's kind of their problem
I've been holding this in for 10 years
and I'm going to say it I am begging
these people to learn to think
psychologically instead of literally so
they're not constantly baffled and
traumatized upon encountering literally
the most common type of sexual fantasy
that people have I guess when you're
only analytic tool is a sledgehammer you
see every problem as an author whose
legs aren't hobbled yet it's frustrating
because there's plenty of more nuanced
criticism of pornography especially when
it's produced coercively or when it
functions as a replacement for actual
sex education but I reject the radical
feminist idea that consuming pornography
is a major cause of violence and I
should know because I'm a very violent
person and I never consume pornography I
guess I also need to address that for
every radical feminist who thinks that
Twilight fanfiction is literally
violence there's also a thousand
misogynistic idiots who will argue that
dark romance fantasies prove that women
really want to be dominated by abusive
alpha males which no stop no fantasizing
about sexy vampires doesn't make you a
willing victim any more than fantasizing
about torpedoing a car holding up
traffic makes you a murder I fantasize
about Mario Kart shelling bad drivers
all the time it doesn't mean I literally
want Bloodshed on the New Jersey
Turnpike unless they're asking for it as
zarra spake we have a name a perfect
name for Fantasy realized it's called
nightmare our violent and twisted
fantasies are unconscious solutions to
the problem of anxiety and really we're
all just seeking pleasure and safety so
probably it's fine right it's fine
a little bit of healthy sadism never
hurt
anyone part four power is it really fine
though we're not done we're not even
close to done I'm just getting warmed up
what feels incomplete to me about the
it's just fantasy argument is that
Twilight is a fantasy yes but it's a
fantasy that reflects something real
about the sexual Dynamics between men
and women I mostly agree with Nancy
Friday's and Michael Bader's
psychological analysis of fantasies but
psychology without material analysis of
power fails to explain some important
things this becomes really obvious with
sexual fantasies involving racial
fetishism for example there's a chapter
of Nancy Friday's book titled big black
men which is exactly what it sounds like
the fantasies of white women who are
turned on by an animalistic stereotype
of black men it's a racial fixation
that's very much present as subtext in
Twilight I leave you alone for 2 minutes
and the Wolves descend Jacob is
indigenous he transforms into an animal
his last name is literally black we were
great spirit Warriors they transformed
to the powerful wolf oh God are the
werewolves lamanites Stephanie I regret
to inform you that the cuck tent is
racist we could try to psychoanalyze all
of this the bigness in question
referring not just to Anatomy but to the
intensity of Desire the exciting taboo
of otherness animalization as a shame
negating device and all of that may be
true but aren't these fantasies still a
reflection and possibly a reinforcement
of unjust political reality in his 2016
essay decolonizing my desire slave play
author Jeremy o' Harris describes his
experience as a black gay teenager who
became erotically fixated on white men
because to him whiteness represented
power and Prestige he concludes that by
obsessing over white bodies and white
validation quote I was failing to exist
I don't see myself as some kind of moral
judge of who's allowed to fantasize
about what but I've noticed people are
usually way less comfortable with
fantasies rooted in racism than they are
with fantasies about powerful men
dominating submissive women but is that
justifiable have men not dominated women
throughout history Stephanie Meyer
didn't invent this story about a male
predator in his female prey out of thin
air don't a lot of girls grow up being
treated as a kind of sexual prey to male
predators
doesn't that have some kind of influence
on the fantasies that women have and
can't fantasy sometimes influence
reality according to criminologist Scott
B the Behavioral Science unit of the FBI
has concluded that serial killers
programmed themselves in childhood to
become murderers through a progressively
intensifying Loop of fantasy I can
confirm this my question is are fantasy
power dynamics simply the result of
political inequality or is there
something inherently vampiric about
sexuality itself according to leapold
Fon sakur masok the guy who masochism is
named after I wish I could have a
perversion named after me according to
masok in love one person must be the
hammer the other the
Anvil is this true is sexuality always
ruled by hierarchy split into binary
roles is there always a hammer and an
anvil a top and a bottom a Dom and a sub
a lover and a beloved uh
lion and a lamb what a stupid
lamb sick masochistic Lion in
heterosexuality the default assumption
is that the man is The Lion and the
woman is the lamb but gay people are
hardly exempt from aligning with these
types of roles top and bottom some
people are born straight and others have
straightness thrust upon them let's call
the situation default heterosexual seom
masochism dhsm remember this cuz I'm
going to say it a lot dhsm this division
of sexuality into bipolar roles
masculine feminine active passive
subject object lover beloved giving
receiving pursuing pursued Predator prey
dominant submissive possessing possessed
conquering surrendering penetrating
penetrated Voris exhibitionistic
sadistic masochistic in reality none of
these rules are interchangeable or even
necessarily correlated being masculine
does not imply being a top and neither
imply being dominant masculinity is
gender expression top is a sexual
position and dominant is a role in a
power Dynamic but in dhsm these roles
are assumed to be bundled together and
assumed to belong to the sexuality of
men when I say satom masochism I don't
just mean the narrow sense of enjoying
or inflicting pain but this whole
dynamic of dominance and submission male
dominance is so much the heterosexual
default that female dominance or femdom
is usually considered a kink that is
it's considered deviant dhsm defines
heterosexuality as the dominance of
women by men men who are perceived as
submissive to women are sometimes called
Gay over such a mascula behavior as
leaning towards a woman pleasuring a
woman walking behind a woman and holding
the baby he sired with a woman dhsm is
woven into so much of our language about
sexuality think about the implications
of the term impotence literally loss of
power implying that phallic sexuality is
fundamentally about power there's a
strong association between masculinity
and predation meat is considered
masculine a feminine man is called a soy
boy Edward Cullen is a vegetarian
vampire he's vegetarian because without
a guilty conscience he would be
incapable of love but it's important
that he be a vampire because his blood
lust gives him his dangerous verile edge
I want my man to be a predator not a cow
a lion says a woman on Tinder who has
traumatic experiences with vegans don't
we all supposedly men hunt while women
gather but in dhsm women become the meat
just looks at you like you're something
to eat in the sexual politics of meat
vegan feminist Carol J Adams argues for
the interrelation of the oppression of
women and the slaughter of animals she
wants to abolish both forms of Cruelty
from human life God you can't Slaughter
animals or objectify women well what are
Men supposed to do for fun now women's
bodies are discussed as flesh to be
consumed castles under siege temples to
be profaned her freshness seal is broken
she becomes used Goods smut made for men
tends to involve degrading women
likewise erotic media for women tends to
involve themes of submission and
surrender feminine masochism pervades
culture Lana Del re says he hit me and
it felt like a kiss he hurt me but it
felt like true love Sylvia Plath says
every woman Ador a fascist from an
egalitarian feminist perspective it's
troubling concerning that not just in
fantasy but in reality satom masochism
often reflects the social political and
sexual domination of women by men
historically psycho Anis considered
default heterosexual stom masochism the
result of biological predisposition
Freud says the sexuality of most male
human beings contains an element of
aggressiveness a desire to subjugate
daddy chill Freud's colleague Helena
Deutch argued likewise that quote
masochism is part of the woman's
anatomical Destiny she thought that
female masochism results from the
inherent pain of women's reproductive
role defloration menstruation and child
birth it's really just a secular version
of the biblical view that women's
Destiny is pain and submission in sorrow
Thou shalt bring forth children and thy
desire shall be to thy husband and he
shall rule over thee a lot of 20th
century feminist theory was devoted to
arguing against this idea of anatomical
Destiny feminists have tended to argue
that male sadism and female masochism
are purely the result of patriarchy of
male social dominance the idea is that
women learn to desire desire submission
from their inferior social position and
Men learn to desire dominating and
degrading women from their Superior
position in the 1980s a common radical
feminist view was that male and female
are not natural categories at all but
that they're constructed through
violence and exploitation analogous to
bisi and proletariat radical feminist
Katherine McKinnon says male and female
are created through the erotization of
dominance and submission man woman sub
object verb object Andrea dorin says men
are distinguished from women by their
commitment to do violence rather than to
be victimized by it notice how at odds
this is with JK Rowling's formulation
sex is real which some radical feminists
would once have considered the
constitutive statement of sexism there's
been a return to anatomical Destiny
lately in the form of turism that is
post-feminist conservative bigotry
against trans people Ring's transphobic
arguments often hinge on an assumption
that males are natural predators and
females are natural prey or as alien sex
inspector Maya forer puts it in the
context of Prisons it is a hoe that
matters women have a hole which men want
to penetrate bluntly the reason we have
men and women's prisons is to keep the
men away from the hes this is anatomical
Destiny at the kindergarten level woman
equals hole man equals pole therefore
man equals Predator woman equals prey I
like the pole and the hole turfs think
the Omega verse is real that men are
anatomical alphas and women are
anatomical omegas Stephanie Meyer takes
a more gender fluid view in the
introduction to femdom Twilight life and
death Stephanie says I've always
maintained that it would have made no
difference if the human were male and
the vampire female it's still the same
story and are there not male masochists
and female ssts masochism is named after
a man a man who once said nothing
Kindles my passion quite so much as
tyranny cruelty and above all
unfaithfulness in a beautiful woman send
him to the tent send him to the
tent of cuckoldry even if there is an
anatomical disposition of men to sadism
and women to masochism disposition is
not Destiny both men and women are
anatomically capable of being the hammer
or the envil the predator or the prey so
I think that feminists are most correct
to point to the history of male social
dominance as the reason for default
gendered roles until the married women's
property Act of 1870 English women were
subject to a system called coverture
meaning that when a woman married her
entire legal existence was subsumed
under that of her husband and she
effectively lost the right to own
property or make contracts in the US it
was only as recently as 1974 that women
won the right to open Independent bank
accounts the same year they started
having sexual fantasies amazing so
historically the erotic and economic
fates of women have been fused it's the
key to historical romance novels like
Pride and Prejudice where the tension is
between Elizabeth's desire for a
marriage of love and her economic need
for a marriage of security incels like
to complain about female hypergamy and
Mr Bennett sits around making sarcastic
quips about it that's right we're coming
from Mr Bennett in this video nothing is
sacred but women's preference for
wealthy powerful Partners is the result
of gender rules that make women
dependent and subservient women are not
biologically attracted to Providers
Elizabeth and then Lydia are initially
attracted to Wickham even though he has
no money in Titanic upper class Rose is
attracted to workingclass Leo in
weathering Heights Catherine is
attracted to feral dog boy heathcliffe
and in Twilight Bella is attracted to
feral dog boy Jacob women are attracted
to disempowered and impoverished men all
the time but because of their social and
economic dependence for most of History
a story about a woman who loves a lower
class man is not a romance it's a
tragedy Catherine says it would degrade
me to marry heathcliffe if the boy is
poor there's no room on the door so I'm
prepared to believe that most of dhsm is
the result of class struggle and not of
genital Anatomy but either way how do we
explain male masochists how do we
explain gay or lesbian people who
practice BDSM or who identify as tops or
bottoms why does there need to be a
hammer or an anvil at all do we need
sexual hierarchy can't we just have a
sexuality based on gentleness and
equality and Humane Democratic Values
well that is exactly the question that
divided feminists in the 1980s a
conflict known as the feminist Sex Wars
and I'm bringing it back let's have a
feminist sex
War so look I'm now going to try to
fairly present the arguments of sex
negative radical feminism which fair
warning can be difficult to hear because
they're kind of saying that your most
intimate desires and relationships are
founded on violence and Injustice and
I'm trans so I'm used to constantly
having to defend my sexuality but
straight people this might be new to you
so strap in you should put your seat Bel
on you should put your seat belt on sex
negative feminism is a backlash against
the sexual revolution of the 60s and70s
the general idea of the sexual
Revolution was that sexuality should be
liberated from Marriage from the state
from religion and from the imperative to
procreate the radical feminist objection
to it was basically that in practice the
sexual Revolution was only a liberation
of men's desire to dominate women
radical feminist Andrea dworin says
quote Freedom that hallowed word is
valued only when when used in reference
to male desire for women Freedom means
only that men are free to use them
sexual Libertarians sometimes imply that
sexual repression is inherently bad but
many women experience violence at the
hands of men whose sexuality is not
repressed enough to those women freedom
of sexuality may seem less important
than freedom from sexuality sometimes
sexual repression is good freedom for
the lion is not freedom for the lamb the
question is is it possible to liberate
sex without liberating violence and for
sex negative feminists the answer is
basically no as they see it we have to
choose between sexuality and women's
rights and we should choose women's
rights this is a tough settle for most
people but okay let's hear it out the
final boss of sex negative feminism is
former academic Sheila Jeff quote the
demolition of heterosexual desire is a
necessary step on the route to women's
Liberation good luck with that now I
love Sheila Jeff I think she's hilarious
but I'm an intellectual Mist I get off
on bad ideas my tastes are
very singular these days Sheila Jeff
Blends in as just another generic
English transphobe these people are a
diamond dozen the problem is that men
doing Woman face are insulting to women
when they're just walking down the
street or sitting in a cafe activities
for which they need an unwilling
audience of women in order to get sexual
excitement she goes on podcasts and
talks about how trans women are
perverted fetishists parasitically
occupying female bodies which yeah yeah
yeah that is now the mainstream
conservative view so thank you for that
Sheila Sheila Jeff actually pioneered a
lot of these transphobic arguments she
walked so that JK Rowling could run give
the devil her du Sheila's 2020
autobiography is titled trigger warning
which should give you some idea of where
she stands in the current culture War
like a hack comedian who hasn't been
funny in 30 years I guess even lesbians
aren't immune to Boomer brainworms sad
but back in the ' 80s and '90s sheilo is
actually saying some genuinely
subversive things not good things but
subversive that quote about demolishing
heterosexual desire is from her 1990
book anticlimax a feminist perspective
on the sexual Revolution which is an
amazingly bad book on sex and gender not
just because of the transphobia not just
because of bizarre claims like that
women today are required to wear
mandatory pumps at the office but
also because of the absurdly Bold stance
she takes on abolishing heterosexuality
which I realize may sound based as the
kids say I'm down with the kids but it
is in fact cringe this book is bad but
it's bad in a way that is legitimately
fascinating in a way that we can all
learn from so according to Sheila the
end goal of feminism is quote the
destruction of heterosexuality as a
system she was influenced by radfem Jill
Johnson who in 1973 said feminism at
heart is a massive complaint lesbianism
is the solution until all women are
lesbians there will be no true political
revolution these people were dead
serious this is not a bit in 1979 Sheila
Jeff co-authored with the Leeds
revolutionary feminist group a paper
titled political lesbianism the case
against heterosexuality if I try to
summarize it you'll think that I'm
drawing a caricature so I'm just going
to read you some direct quotes and I
encourage you to go read it yourself to
verify that I'm not taking things out of
context quote serious feminists have no
choice but to abandon heterosexuality
men are the enemy heterosexual women are
collaborators With the Enemy attached to
all forms of sexual behavior are
meanings of dominance and submission
power and powerlessness conquest and
humiliation any woman who takes part in
a heterosexual couple helps to shore up
male Supremacy by making its foundations
stronger so how do you think this paper
was received by the women's Liberation
movement you probably won't be surprised
to hear that it was not hugely popular
when Sheila presented these arguments on
a panel the Socialist feminist Lynn
seagull said the speech made her feel as
if she had been shot Sheila says at the
time we were not able to understand why
the paper had provoked such a virent
attack I can't imagine why feminists
would be so hostile to me simply
pointing out that all women in
relationships with men are
counterrevolutionary traitors one hears
such arguments and what can one say but
Sheila Jeff as Jack halber stem said if
Sheila Jeff didn't exist Camille Pia
would have had to invent her I promise
it's funny if you know who these people
are please clap I mean it's one thing to
seek Community with other women who
renounce relationships with men and are
therefore excluded from the vicarious
power that comes with that every
marginalized Community has a separatist
Fringe which can be a valid choice but
where things get cuckoo bananas is when
you insist that all feminists must
renounce relationships with men because
I'm sorry to say but that will literally
never happen and this kind of thing only
divides the left when we should be
United against the Real Enemy the vosai
counterrevolutionaries but there's an
abstract kind of logic to Sheila's
argument you could put it like this
premise one power imbalances in sexual
relationships are oppressive premise two
under patriarchy men as a class have
power over women therefore any sexual
relationship between a man and a woman
involves a power imbalance therefore all
heterosexual relationships are
oppressive therefore men are the enemy
and women who date them are gender
traitors is this argument wrong why is
it wrong well it's wrong because libido
laughs in the face of reason you can't
just reason people into being LGBT
Sheila I've tried it's not a lifestyle
Choice Bella I was born this way I can't
help it so in anticlimax Sheila makes an
interesting shift she still Advocates
abolishing heterosexuality but she
redefines heterosexuality as sexual
desire that eroticizes power difference
the reason for the redefinition seems to
be that instead of feuding with
heterosexual feminists Sheila is now
feuding with lesbian stom masochists
whom she argues are in fact heterosexual
because they eroticize power and
eroticizing power includes anything from
top bottom Dynamics to Kink to
interracial relationships to good
old-fashioned penetration so according
to this view gay men who have
penetrative sex are in fact heterosexual
because they uphold the oppressive power
of the phace that subjugates women gay
women who identify as Butch or fem they
are heterosexual because they're role
playing the oppressive dynamics of
heterosexuality the only true
homosexuals according to Sheila Jeff are
couples who eroticize equality so what
does that mean it means no penetration
no tops or bottoms no kinky and
no gender expression apart from the
androgynous Spock core aesthetic Sheila
Jeff was rocking so what is left of sex
when you only eroticize equality well
egalitarian sex turns out to be two
ideally non-trans seexual women who are
the same age race and class with the
same androgynous haircut lying side by
side no one on top or bottom just gently
non- aggressively Whispering sweet words
of Consciousness raising to each other
throughout the night Join the Revolution
the tender loving twinsest Revolution
you're probably getting very irritated
listening to this I am also irritated
but I want to be very clear about why
I'm irritated I have no problem at all
with Sheila Jeff's defining sex as
whatever it means to her a courtesy
she's never extended to anyone else in
her entire life but we should extend it
to her on principle if sex for you means
tender Consciousness raising sessions
between the sheets with your andr galp
Pals by all means continue we should
also acknowledge that egalitarian sex is
genuinely marginalized there are ways of
having sex like you know where both
participants are equally active and
there's no clear dichotomy of giver and
receiver mainstream straight and gay
culture dismisses egalitarian or
non-penetrative sex as immature as not
real sex as not going all the way gay
dating app grinder only added side as a
selectable position in 2022 the
unthinkability of egalitarian sex to
many people shows how deep dhsm goes so
Sheila Jeff is correct to defend the
legitimacy of egalitarian sex against
dhsm but again the problem is when you
declare that your version of egalitarian
sex is the only legitimate one and that
everyone else is upholding the
oppressive system I find this to be a
deeply lazy incurious and unempathetic
way of thinking it's unsch this attitude
of total indifference to what's going on
in other people's minds why is Sheila
like this I think it's because she feels
that she used to be a heterosexual until
the age of 28 when she made a rational
conscious choice to become an
egalitarian androgynous trans
exclusionary non-s masochistic lesbian
and she thinks that every other woman
can and should make that choice she says
in trigger warning quote in the late 19
7s I rejected heterosexuality and chose
to become a lesbian Lynn Alderson
explained to me in patient detail the
reasons to become a lesbian she
describes how one evening she was with
her boyfriend and his guy friend
watching a TV drama in which a school
boy put his hand up a teacher's skirt
quote I looked at the two young men
beside me neither of whom looked
particularly affected and then I had an
epiphany I could not see the point of
spending time in the company of those
who were members of the oppressor class
I chose from that day to the present to
have only women in my personal and
emotional life I was suddenly open to
the feelings I was increasingly having
towards other women not necessarily
sexual but profoundly emotional feelings
so this is the story of how Sheila Jeff
quit heterosexuality and so can you and
again I'm not saying that Sheila Jeff
isn't valid or that she's not a real
lesbian no we're not doing that her
experience is valid for whatever that's
worth but it isn't typical most people
do not experience their sexual
orientation as the result of a rational
process of consciously deciding the
correct course of action after
considering the advice of trusted
colleagues many heterosexual women
totally agree with Sheila Jeff that #
men are trash and they love to say I
wish I were a lesbian and talk about how
gross and cringe heterosexuality is and
yet they continue being straight because
libido does not follow reason for most
of us AOS is an Archer we feel
penetrated by something outside
ourselves possessed by this alien desire
I can't help but wonder if what sex
negative feminists fear in sexuality is
in fact AOS not just the physical
penetration of heterosexual intercourse
but the emotional penetration of
romantic love and the loss of
self-possession that comes with it none
of them belong to themselves anymore and
the sickest part is the genes tell them
they're happy about it telling yourself
that everything you do is because of
reason and logic soothes the anxiety of
uncertainty and it disguises the reality
that none of us really have that much
control over anything not even our own
desires and isn't that the point of
fantasies like Twilight they make it
feel safe to surrender to this
frightening overwhelming Force inside us
I feel like the only reasonable view for
radical feminists to take is that
changing Society will change sexuality
but instead Sheila argues the opposite
that we should change Society by
changing sexuality by abolishing it
Sheila is aware that most people can't
freely direct their own sexual
orientation through acts of the will she
even cites a feminist therapist Who
quote encouraged her clients to
democratize their relationships the
couples kept returning to her with a new
problem they were unable to summon up
desire love yes but not desire I think
many even most people find that equality
like wisdom is not exciting and Sheila's
solution for these people is celibacy so
to recap Sheila thinks that women should
live in female only communities where no
one has sex but everyone shares a kind
of vague homoeroticism and I feel like
this type of Utopia already exists and
in fact has existed for hundreds of
years it's called a Convent doesn't
Sheila Jeff want to be a nun this is
where I belong it's my home my family
it's my life has she reinvented
Christianity well no she's invented
something worse because at least
Christianity is honest about the fact
that our will does not control our lusts
you have to live the life you were born
to live in mainstream Christianity the
idea that we can simply choose to live a
sinless life is known as pelagian heresy
this was refuted by Augustine the North
African Theologian who argued that we
all have lusted in our heart because we
are of a fallen nature we inherit the
sin of of Adam we are stained from birth
by the filth of concupisent and you
might say aren't you overthinking
Twilight no no is the children who are
underthinking it Augustine's claim is
that our will can overcome Temptation
with God's grace but Christians do not
make the psychologically batshit claim
that we can consciously direct our lust
towards virtue sexuality can be
repressed or resisted or it can be
sublimated into creative or spiritual
energy but free will plays very little
role in either love or lust so Sheila
Jeff's feminism is actually more
repressive than Christianity because at
least in Christianity you get to talk
about how sinful and wretched you are my
favorite activity part
five
death sometimes late at night I read
Twilight and I wonder am I prepared for
death is anyone I've argued that sex
negative feminists are wrong about
psychology freedom and fantasy but are
they wrong about sex well not entirely
it sounds like an extreme provocation
when rad fem say things like attached to
all forms of sexual behavior are
meanings of dominance and submission
power and powerlessness conquest and
humiliation but among theorists of
sexuality across the ideological
Spectrum there's a surprising amount of
consensus on this point radical
feminism's mortal enemy Dr father says
the history of human civilization shows
Beyond any doubt that there is an
intimate connection between cruelty and
the sexual Instinct sexual
uh libertarian Camille Pia says All
Phases of procreation are ruled by
appetite sexual intercourse from kissing
to penetration consists of movements of
barely controlled cruelty and
consumption in other words there's a
pretty wide consensus that human
sexuality is in fact vampiric that is
it's ruled by hierarchy cruelty and
consumption the real disagreement is
about why that is and what we should do
about it let's address the why question
why is sexuality vampiric the radical
feminist response is because of
patriarchy radfems argue satom masochism
simply mirrors the social reality of
male Supremacy even when inverted in
female dominance or when practiced by
same-sex couples whom redfm say are just
imitating heterosexuality and sure I
think patriarchy is largely responsible
for default male dominance but I think
satom masochism in general has roots
deeper than political inequality let's
start by thinking about why sexuality
even exists in the first place why can't
we just be
normal we can't be normal because we're
not bacteria we can't reproduce by
mitosis in the scene where Bella and
Edward are first introduced to each
other they're in a science lab looking
through a microscope at the stages of
mitosis proas metaphase anaphase now you
could say that's just a coincidence it
doesn't mean anything okay well maybe
everything's just a coincidence maybe
nothing means anything maybe life is
pointless asexual reproduction is fision
the cell duplicates its chromosomes and
rips itself in half creating two
daughter cells so what happens to the
Mother cell when it divides is Vision
death or is it eternal life well it
depends what we mean by death I promise
this is about Twilight wait for it death
is the disillusion of the boundaries
that Define individual existence each
individual thing is distinguished from
other things by its edges the membrane
of a cell the skin of an animal the
border of a country in asexual
reproduction the life of the species
requires the death of the individual the
Mother cell must split to reproduce
sexual reproduction also contains a
paradox of life and death but instead of
fision we have fusion and fertilization
where two gametes merge to create new
life sexuality also involves Fusion at a
social and emotional level your partner
is your other half because in love two
people become one entity the Bible says
two married people leave their father
and mother and become one flesh even if
they don't biologically reproduce the
couple is a new social Union that comes
into being at the expense of their
former Family Ties and of the boundaries
that used to define two separate
individuals so love and sex create new
life but they also involve a kind of
death in 1912 the psychoanalyst Sabina
sheline published a paper called
destruction as the cause of becoming
which sent Freud reeling into a thought
spiral that led him to the theorize the
Death Drive the question Spiel rine
wanted to answer is quote why does the
most powerful Drive the reproductive
Drive in addition to the expected
positive feelings Harbor negative
feelings such as anxiety and disgust
Spiel rine is trying to explain the
ambivalence the element of fear and
trembling in every sexual
encounter don't be a coward she sees the
cellular merging of the two gametes this
creation of new life from the
destruction of the p parent cells as an
image representing the emotional
conflicts of sexuality erotic love is
always a threat to our sense of self to
our identity as a distinct individual
have begun to
blur it's similar to The Terror and awe
of mystical experiences encounters with
God or psychedelic Oneness where you
both fear and desire losing the edges of
your ego in s Teresa of aila's mystical
encounter with the angel she quote saw
in his hand a long Spear of gold and at
the point there seemed to be a little
fire he appeared to me to be thrusting
it at times into my heart and to pierce
my very entrails when he drew it out he
seemed to draw them out also and to
leave me all on fire with a great love
of God the pain was so great that it
made me moan and yet so surpassing was
the sweetness of this excessive pain
that I could not wish to be rid of it
now the obvious atheist thing to say is
that this is just like a repressed
Renaissance woman getting off on Jesus
and yes there's obviously a sexual
element to this but is that all couldn't
it also be that both mystical and sexual
experiences penetrate the edges of the
self blurring the line between self and
other can be ecstatic or terrifying or
both it's like when you eat too many
mushrooms and melt into the Universal
Mind lattice whenever boundaries become
unstable a Cris of identity occurs
xenophobic people experience immigration
as a violation of the nation's borders
Build That Wall Build That Wall Build
That Wall Build That Wall it's a crisis
of national identity they conceptualize
as Invasion I think that paranoia about
vaccines is of a similar type the
physical boundary of our bodies is our
skin which is punctured by the
needle the government is coercing us
into being being injected penetrated it
causes deep fears about bodily Integrity
that people rationalize with conspiracy
theories for radical feminist Andrea
dorin intercourse is inherently Invasion
its occupation its Annihilation dworin
views penetration as an atrocity
committed against women by men
tantamount to colonization and war
crimes I think she overstates the case
somewhat is it really Invasion if the
Invader was invaded in the argument is
that that women are coerced into
consenting that no woman would consent
to intercourse without coercion and you
can decide for yourself if you find that
owering or extremely condescending I
think penetration can be
reconceptualized as giving as offering
as an act of service but let's be honest
most of the time penetration is
associated with
dominance don't men have sexual paranoia
of their own in Romance men fear
viscosity the overly attached
girlfriend in sex men sometimes fear
engulfment devouring castration losing
part of themselves and the wom their
precious bodily fluids women sense my
power and they seek the life Essence not
all fears are equally valid I do think
the penetrated partner is made more
vulnerable in most cases if I may
adjudicate as the tyresius in this
debate in both penetration and devouring
the boundaries between people are
violated violation may be fundamental to
sexuality even when there is no
penetration Freud's partial drives oral
anal and phallic all involve the
movement of a substance into or out of
the body simply the act of stripping
naked destroys a boundary and at the
interior emotional level desire is a
wound subjectively desire feels
violating and Carson says when I desire
you a part of me is gone your lack is my
lack I would not be in want of you
unless you had partaken of me the lover
reasons a hole is being gnawed in my
vitals says safo theocritus says you
have sucked my blood this is why
vampirism is a metaphor for sexuality in
Twilight and in most vampire media in
Midnight Sun we learn what Edward is
thinking next to Bella in biology
holding his breath to avoid quote
sinking my teeth through that fine thin
see-through skin to the heart wet
pulsing there's a reason my books have a
lot of Innocence masculine and feminine
sexual hazards are Blended in Vampires
who both penetrate you and devour your
precious bodily fluids they have an
androgynous appeal both male and female
vampires are capable of penetrating and
capable of sucking it's probably one
reason there's so many LGBT vampires and
lesbian vampires in particular the
lesbian vampire is an oral stist for
Freud the oral stage is quote
cannibalistic pregenital sexual
organization here sexual activity has
not yet been separated from the
ingestion of food the sexual aim
consists in the incorporation of the
object adult sexuality develops out of
infantile Roots beginning with the
hunger of her mommy's milk Freud
considers it an infantile regression but
I for one stand by the oral stage I
think it's a fine
stage BS are are little vampires they
drink sustenance from what they love
vampirism is a subgenre of cannibalism
and cannibalism is usually connected in
some way with the urge to merge I don't
even know where you end and I begin
Reddit user Susi MIM bavan explains the
thing about Vore that appeals to me is
the closeness and intimacy between the
two parties involved I mean it's
literally letting someone inside you in
a weird and Abstract way it's really
cute think of it like cuddling taken to
the extreme aw these are not realistic
cannibal fantasies most people into Vore
have no interest in literally consuming
human flesh but of course there's always
that one in a million psycho who takes
things too far and ruins it for everyone
cannibal lust killer Jeffrey dmer claims
he elected victims based on physical
Beauty killing and eating them quote not
because I was angry with them not
because I hated them but because I
wanted to keep them with me possess them
permanently it was a way of uh making me
feel that uh they were a part of me male
serial killers they don't even make use
of the skin even dmer outlandish crimes
are just a morally deranged enactment of
totally commonplace erotic themes
possession dominance Fusion eternal life
and death French philosopher and pervert
George Bai says quote the urge towards
love pushed to its limit is an urge
toward death what do does physical
eroticism signify if not a violation of
the very being of its practitioners a
violation bordering on death bordering
on murder love is fusion and fusion
entails a kind of death death and
reproduction are deeply connected in
human symbolism most religious
Traditions connect death to some form of
rebirth reincarnation Resurrection
Rapture many people feel that having
children is their path to immortality
and that's true in away but in another
sense you're raising the generation that
will replace you in literature and
mythology love often leads to death
Romeo and Juliet Hades and panie Tristan
and isol Madam bovery Anna Corina Jack
Titanic Shakespeare says desire is death
the French call orgasm lean Quan
Twilight's epigraph is Genesis 27 but of
the tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil Thou shalt not eat of it for in the
day that thou eatest thereof Thou shalt
surely die the fruit of the Forbidden
tree brings lust and death into the
world James 1:15 then when lust hath
conceived it bringeth forth sin and sin
when it is finished bringeth forth death
is there any other YouTuber Who quotes
scripture as much as I do I feel like
we're always cracking open the goddamn
Bible well crack open your Bibles Romans
6:23 for the wages of sin is death but
the gift of God is eternal life through
Jesus Christ Our Lord so lust is death
sin is death but the death of Jesus
Christ is eternal life Christians are
united with Christ and incorporated into
his sacrifice in the ritual blood
drinking of the Eucharist sacrifice
desire crucifixion reproduction death
and Resurrection all of these ideas are
symbolically related in the western
imagination and this is the network of
associations Stephanie Meyer evokes in
Twilight before her wedding Bella has
bloody nightmares anticipating vampire
trans transformation and I assume
symbolizing deoration wedding JNS the
marriage is violently consummated
leaving Bella bruised and instantly
pregnant the baby is a vampire sucking
the life from her body childbirth is
agonizing death has any other popular
author ever dwelled so much on the
violence of childbirth Bella's body is
destroyed giving birth to reneesme the
baby cracks her spine it bites her
breast her baby crazed sister-in-law per
forms a C-section without anesthesia the
book is even more graphic Bella is
vomiting blood it's nauseating to read
Edward saves Bella by injecting his
Venom and doing chest compressions which
begins her excruciating transformation
quote I wanted to raise my arms and Claw
my chest open and rip my heart from it
anything to get rid of this torture so
she suffers for 3 Days on the slab after
which she Rises reborn as a vampire can
you think of anyone else who died in
agony only to to be resurrected 3 days
later I'm coming up blank I got nothing
for Stephanie Meyer child birth is
crucifixion it's death that gives
eternal life and if Twilight makes it
explicit some of the satom masochistic
subtext of Christianity 50 Shades of
Gray takes it even further Christian's
name is literally Christian Anna is tied
in cruciform pose while Sacred Music by
Thomas Talis
plays Anastasia is Jesus in this scene
like Bella is Jesus in childbirth we're
meant to understand that this is sacred
pain sacred sex sacred violence does
Christianity have a satom masochistic
subtext or does BDSM have a Christian
[Music]
subtext take a hit leave a comment
either way my argument has a lot of
biblical support in the Book of Genesis
God creates the sex binary through the
violence of vision he takes the rib out
of Adam and makes Eve Adam calls her
Flesh of My Flesh bone of my bones then
in marriage the two Sexes become one
flesh again through the violence of
fusion can we talk about the sanctity of
sex and violence I promise this is about
Twilight okay I'm not going to go off on
some wild tangent in a video about
Twilight like eroticism sanctity is a
matter of boundaries the sacred is
contrasted with the profane the word
profan profane comes from the Latin
profanum meaning before the temple
outside the temple so the sacred is
what's in the temple it's what's set
apart as close to God or Gods religion
and ritual impose order on the world
creating distinctions between the sacred
and the profane it sounds weird to say
that sex and violence are sacred because
aren't sex and violence the number one
things that religious people are always
whining about well yes and no God said
to Moses Thou shalt not kill a simple
commandment the sort of thing you can
carve in stone nevertheless Deuteronomy
2016 says in the cities of the Nations
the Lord your God is giving you as an
inheritance do not leave alive anything
that breathes completely destroy them
the Hittites and the amorites and the
Canaanites and the and as the Lord your
God has commanded you well that sounds
an awful lot like killing to me a ding I
mean it's only the book of Deuteronomy
and we're already wiping out entire
cities kill everyone now so maybe the
Commandment Thou shalt not kill only
means don't kill Israelites in fact that
is what it means the Canaanites don't
have a covenant with God so them
condone first degree murder The Killing
Israelites is not entirely off the table
either for example according to
Leviticus
2013 say it with me if a Man Lies with a
male as with a woman both of them have
committed an Abomination they shall
surely be un alived
y okay so no killing except the
Canaanites and the gays the exceptions
are stocking so the Commandment isn't
really Thou shalt not kill it's Thou
shalt not kill unless likewise Leviticus
17 seems to prohibit the slaughter of
animals unless you kill them
sacrificially at the Tabernacle in the
Sacred Space you know Christians tend
not to read Leviticus but I do because I
enjoy violence and I hate myself
Leviticus is also important context for
the entire story of Christianity Jesus
is the Lamb of God that taketh away the
sins of the world what does that mean
what does that mean it doesn't make any
sense unless you're familiar with
Leviticus and you understand that
killing a lamb is a ritual of atonement
is a ritual of atonement the Tabernacle
of Moses was like a godamn Chanty Town
slaughter house the sacred barbecue
sorry I'm doing a lot of blasphemies but
frankly I think God is bored with you
people I think he enjoys my Innovative
interpretations a lamb had to be
sacrificed every morning and every
evening in addition to all the sin and
guilt sacrifices when Solomon dedicated
the temple we're told he sacrificed
22,000 oxen and
120,000 sheep imagine the blood imagine
the blood the elevator in The Shining
doesn't even come close we can't talk
about vampire romance without
understanding the symbolism of blood a
paradox in Leviticus is that blood is
both cleansing and unclean we're told
that menstruating women are unclean a
woman who gives birth is unclean eating
blood is forbidden sorry Vamps but when
a woman has been made unclean through
the blood of irregular menstruation or
childbirth how does she atone and become
clean again well by sacrificing an
animal and spilling its blood and people
have been trying to understand this
Paradox for thousands of years I'm not
going to pretend that I have it all
figured out but I feel like it has
something to do with blood representing
a transition between life and death
Leviticus 17 forbids eating blood
because the life of every creature is
its blood its blood is its life when is
blood spilled when a child is born
beginning life and when a lamb's throat
is cut ending life what a stupid lamb
could we say that blood is
Lial it's super it's Lial it's uncanny
it's object another explanation comes
from George Bai who argues quote
whatever is the subject of a Prohibition
is basically sacred the sacred World
depends on limited acts of transgression
so all societies have taboos usually
governing food sex reproduction blood
violence dead bodies you know the good
stuff but Tai's argument is that every
taboo has exceptions paradoxically
permitted transgressions and those
permitted transgressions simply are the
sacred Thou shalt not kill unless the
unless is the permitted transgression is
the sacred the Commandment Thou shalt
not commit adultery could be rephrased
as Thou shalt not have sex unless unless
it's with the person who you're married
to for the purpose of procreation or
whatever it is you people do sex is
probably taboo for the same reason that
killing is Rene girad says sexuality is
impure or because it has to do with
violence unregulated sex leads to abuse
seduction assault disease parentless
children defenseless women cheating
jealousy rivalry literally the Trojan
War and we could argue about how
effective marriage really is at
preventing those things but in theory
sex like killing has to be contained
within the boundaries of the Sacred in
this case marriage batai says the
initial sexual act constituting marriage
is a permiss violation if sacrifice is
sacred Slaughter then marriage is sacred
sex I wonder if a wedding is also a kind
of sacrifice it takes place on an altar
usually where sacrifices happen who's
the sacrificial lamb well I assume the
bride she's the Virgin on the altar at
least the symbolic version Twilight uses
evocative imagery of red splashed all
over white Purity and blood life and
death people say your wedding is your
first funeral the bride is going to die
to beget life that makes her sacrificial
Christlike a wedding is a ritualized
transgression of the usual taboo on sex
and these dynamics of taboo and
transgression make human sex and
violence fundamentally different from
natural animal sex and violence I think
it's wrong to conclude as Paul Shephard
does that quote there is a danger in all
carnivores including humans of confusing
the two kinds of venial aggression
loving and hunting human sexual
aggression is not like animal predation
it's conceptual rather than instinctive
Bai says quote the object some
undiscriminating animal is after is not
what is desired the object is forbidden
sacred and the Very prohibition attached
to it is what arouses the desire the
idea that the taboo creates the desire
explains the element of profanation in
sadistic fantasy the word sadism is
named after 18th century French author
and sex criminal the Marquee dad dad was
convicted on charges of debauchery and
IM moderate libertinage and imprison in
the best steal where he wrote 120 days
of Sodom a heartwarming classic beloved
to this day by children of all ages
debauchery and IM moderate libertin age
sounds very quaint very Charming but
let's be clear dad was drugging and
abusing sex workers he tortured some
folks we tortured some folks jenz is
canceling the Marquee dad is nothing
sacred 120 days of Sodom I don't know if
I can accurately summarize this book and
a way that's even allowed on YouTube
I'll try um four wealthy Libertines
imprison a group of youths in a castle
where old prostitutes tell stories of
every conceivable blasphemy crime and
perversion and you did it at my birthday
dinner then the whole thing escalates
into an orgy of you know rape and un
alement still a better love story than
I'm bringing this up because doad
illustrates bai's point that the
transgressive is desired because it is
forbidden personally I don't find sod's
work sexy if anything it's funny like in
the way that John Waters is funny
Advocate cannibalism eat because
comedy like sexuality relies on
transgression the things described in
120 days of Sodom like bodily fluids are
excreted on a crucifix which is then
deployed in unspeakable acts of oh my
God this is not Natural Animal
aggression when sod's Champion Camille
Pia says Nature's reality is sodian red
in tooth and Claw this is a misuse of
sod's name because there's nothing
natural about 120 days of Sodom there is
aggression in nature dolphins for
example are sexually violent don't
Google it you you don't need this in
your brain but dolphins do not commit
sex crimes because dolphins do not have
laws in the criminal justice system
sexually based offenses are considered
especially no
accusations friendly only human violence
is ritualized it always stands in some
relation to Taboo whether it's sacred
permitted transgression or profane
criminal transgression Jeffrey dmer
sketched a diagram of a shrine he was
planning to create an altar on which to
display his victim's skulls this is not
animal predation Lions do not build
shrines for the skulls of the Lambs the
element of blasphemy and disad is the
most telling in sadistic fantasy the
sacred is invoked so it can be profaned
Bai says quote beauty is desired in
order that it may be befouled the
polluting or despoiling of beauty is a
major theme in male oriented smut fil
FMS there's a lot of fluids being you
know blasted everywhere I think this is
a real point of conflict within
heterosexuality a lot of women want to
be intensely desired by men a lot of
women fantasize about being virtuosic
ravished by men but far fewer women
Swoon at the prospect of being befouled
I mean some women do right for anything
you can think of there's someone who's
into it but feminine submissive
fantasies if anything tend to sanctify
sexuality before it was called 50 Shades
of Gray This Twilight fanfiction was
titled Master of the Universe master of
the universe is not what you call a man
it's what you call a god what if God was
one of
us by submitting to a Godlike man the
masochistic woman elevates herself
whereas a sadistic man elevates himself
by putting down a woman masculine
sadistic fantasy usually involves
degradation and despoiling of the woman
her beauty is a sacred Temple that he
profanes with his in this case not so
precious bodily fluids we want to drench
your angel wings that carry you to
heaven with our sticky gooey disgusting
so in a way sism and masochism are in
fact not complimentary at all the
philosopher delus recounts a joke that
tells of the meeting between a sist and
a masochist the masochist says hurt me
the sadist replies no Christian Gray is
not as he claims a SST I get off and
punishing women women who look like you
like your mother he's a masochist
fantasy of a sadist in reality a SST and
a masochist do not belong together the
ideal pairing is probably two masochists
who alternate taking the AC of role in
masochistic play acting you know what
maybe we should abolish heterosexuality
I'm sorry sh sha Jeff you were right
let's return to our question from three
tangents ago why is sexuality vampiric
why is it so hard to make sexuality
conformed to Humane political ideals of
pacifism and equality I think part of
the answer is that sexuality inherently
involves the violation of boundaries and
the overcoming of barriers something has
to rip the bodice and there's a lot of
bodices to be ripped it's not just
Freud's guilt shame and anxiety it's not
just Nancy Friday's lifetime of women's
rules against sex it's also the taboo
against sex that allows Society to
function it's the fear of reproduction
and death the fear of losing your
identity and boundaries to desire and to
Fusion all of this must be overcome for
climax to be reached and we can
conceptualize the overcoming as a
conquest or a surrender but there is no
pacifying the emotional experience of
eroticism it's conflicted by Nature
Bittersweet eroticism is a dialectic of
life and death love and hate tenderness
and violence taboo and transgression
separation and unity and that's why
Edward Cullen is a Vampire the threat of
losing yourself of losing your
boundaries will always be a source of
ambivalence no matter how egalitarian or
how permissive society's attitudes
towards sex become satom masochistic
fantasy has psychological Origins that
cannot be fully explained by leftist
analysis of social hierarchy nor
abolished by Consciousness raising or
revolutionary action sexuality is not a
pure innocent thing that gets perverted
by corrupt Society no I agree with
Augustine that lust is inherently
perverted and society's role is to
channel it into Outlets that minimize
violence and those Outlets may include
novels and movies and erotica and
problematic ships none of which are to
blame for perverting sexuality these
things are an expression of something
turbulent within us which for me is
symbolized by the Sea the inherently
erotic sea why is the ocean inherently
erotic well because of the rhythmic
expansion contraction cycles of her wave
motion yes of course but also because
she's mother because she's life she's
birth she's death She's the Primal
horror of Horrors and the sweet womb of
mother Knight she is erotic because she
beckons and we come Stephanie Meyer is
of course aware of all this maybe not
consciously but it's all there it's all
in Twilight Edward and Bella's ecstatic
Union takes place where in the sea as
Emily Dickinson said rowing in Eden ah
the sea might I put more tonight in
thee
penetration I know what you get up to
Emily and I'm reporting you to Sheila
Jeff
part six
identity I'm once again wearing an
evening gown at home in the middle of
the night to film a YouTube video by
myself well I do it for you the longest
Twilight book is midnight sun this thing
is like a blunt
weapon Midnight Sun is the book that
retells Twilight from Edward's
perspective here's a question if the
wish fulfillment fantasy element of
Twilight relies on readers identifying
with Bella why would would Stephanie
Meyer rewrite it from Edward's
perspective why would snow Queen's ice
dragon copy Stephanie Meyer yet again
rewriting 50 Shades of Gray from
Christian's perspective well because
she's a hack who likes money and wants
to wear Stephanie's skin but a lot of
Twilight fans actually wanted Midnight
Sun why why would you want to spend 800
Pages inside the head of the world's
most dangerous predator well let's maybe
put it this way when you were a kid what
was the most popular week of programming
on the Discovery Channel kelp week
sardine week no Shark Week why
because sharks do murders I'm the
world's most dangerous predator humans
are attracted to Predators because we're
attracted to power and we're usually
attracted to power not because we're
masochists who want to be prayed upon
but because we want to be powerful
ourselves it's what philosopher
Frederick nudson called the will to
power we're attracted to Predators
because it flatters our egos to
recognize part part of ourselves in
sharks or cats or Wolves whereas prey
animals calling someone a sheep or a pig
is usually an insult in my video on Envy
I argued that people resent power
actually that's a pretty terrible
summary of that video just go watch the
video and there's a usually right-wing
version of this argument that says we
live in a victimhood culture where all
discourse is grievance privilege is
despised everyone rhetorically positions
themselves as the innocent lamb Christ
on the cross I'm so oppressed but
resentment is just frustrated Will To
Power it's derivative of the will to
power you hate it cuz you ain't it and
resentment hurts Envy is the sin that
gives no pleasure so usually the path of
least resistance is to feel powerful by
identifying with power why do poor
downtrodden people support Rich powerful
politicians it's not just because they
see themselves as temporarily
embarrassed millionaires it's because
people identify with politicians they
support and and that makes them feel
powerful vicariously why are so many
weird nerds ready to die in battle for
Elon Musk isn't it because they identify
with him and so they feel that his power
is also theirs they're like the boy who
resolves the edus complex his feelings
of rivalry and jealousy toward his
father by identifying with his father
for similar reasons women sometimes
identify with male predators in the
1980s California was terrorized by
Richard Ramirez aka the nightstalker who
brutally murdered at least 13 people fan
girls and crime groupies adored him
throughout the trial with one admirer
eventually marrying him many such cases
Ted Bundy also married one of his fans
Jeffrey dmer got lots of fan mail from
women who thought they were attracted to
him Ramirez himself offered a theory
about his appeal to these women saying
quote I think the girls are attracted to
me because they can relate to me I think
that's essentially correct attraction to
serial killers is based on identific
ation with the criminal these women are
not masochists who want to be victims
they're aspiring to be the final girl to
Vicarious power in her book Savage
appetites Rachel Monroe says of serial
killer groupy quote in a world where
masculinity meant power and power meant
violence some women would always opt to
align themselves with that violence and
exert their own perverse power through
love it was a way to feel special chosen
but it was an ugly kind of special
tainted with other people's pain in 2018
a small publisher told Rachel we used to
do zombies and vampires but that's going
nowhere it's all true crime now has True
Crime replaced the vampire romance if so
I think that's unfortunate because
Jeffrey dmer has real victims and Edward
Cullen does not I feel like this is an
area where fiction is superior to
reality whenever I finish one of my
serial killer research binges I'm always
left with a feeling of disappointment
these are men with something less not
with something more what we really want
serial killers to be is Hannibal Lecter
powerful glamorous artistic and deadly
he combines the power of raw animal
aggression with the power of
sophisticated civilized culture that's
why he's daddy True Crime is shark weak
for grown-ups we're transfixed by the
beauty of power and the power of beauty
and in case this needs to be said the
desire for power is a facet of human
personality that is not going to be
solved by lesbianism as if lesbians
never desired powerful women as if no
gay woman has ever wanted Mommy to step
on her like come on pay attention but
it's true that for most women
identifying with power means identifying
with men for most of History merging
with a man has been many women's only
plausible path to power traditional
marriage strongly incentivizes women to
identify with their husbands and enjoy
his power vicariously as a 1966 Supreme
Court opinion put it though the husband
and wife are one the one is the husband
most married women still take their
husband's surname symbolically subsuming
her identity into his on the altar
Isabella Swan becomes Mrs Edward Cullen
she is he now even if it's anti-feminist
for a woman to fantasize about obtaining
Power by merging with a man it still has
to be said that this is not really
masochism it's still a kind of power
fantasy masochism would be if in
Breaking Dawn Bell just gets eaten by
the vampires the end but that's not what
happens according to Stephanie meyer.com
breaking Dawn's cover is a metaphor for
Bella's progression throughout the
entire Saga she began as the weakest
player on the board the pawn she ended
as the strongest the queen likewise 50
Shades of Gray concludes with
Christian's admission that Anastasia is
topping from the bottom you're topping
from the bottom Mrs
Gray but I can live with that isn't that
the fan fanty that it's really the woman
who controls male power who's topping
from the bottom I think some degree of
male identification is a normal part of
women's experience in weaing Heights
Catherine says I love him because he's
more myself than I am I am heathcliffe
Ursula kwinn says I am the generic he as
in a writer knows which side his bread
is buttered on that's me the writer him
I am a man men are viewed as default and
women tend to be fluent in adopting a
masculine perspective it makes me sad
that when a woman writes a book from a
woman's perspective pretty much only
women read it whereas I read books
written by men about men's perspective
all the time and this could be why men
don't think they understand women
because you don't read our perspective
as much as we read yours this is
relevant to understanding Twilight as
fantasy because if readers are
identifying with Edward rather than
Bella then this isn't female masochism
is it the reader isn't being dominated
by Edward because she is Edward on this
interpretation romance fantasies with an
alpha monster hero are simply vicarious
power fantasies but to reduce the
reader's experience to male
identification is also too simple I've
been sitting in front of this fruit tart
for 40 minutes I'm going to start eating
it it's happening in her essay the
androgynous reader romance writer Laura
kinale argues that romance novels have
nothing to do with women's relationships
with actual men but rather quote the
whole Adventure is an interior one
romance fantasy then is basically a
Psycho Drama between different elements
of the reader's own personality quote
romance reflects the exploration and
Reconciliation of male elephants male
elephants are you you kidding me romance
reflects the exploration and
Reconciliation of male elements within
the female reader the romance hero
represents the readers animus the man
within her aggressive adventurous
masculine side so unlike the strict
subject object dichotomy Laura muli
describes as the male gaze in cinema the
female Viewpoint in Romance is
inherently gender fluid kinale says
quote it is myopic to believe that just
because the reader is female she is
confined to the heroin's character the
female reader is the hero and also is
the heroine as object of the hero's
interest the heroine in a romance novel
is not a character the reader identifies
with the way you might identify with a
superhero and some aspirational way
instead the heroin is a placeholder for
the reader who both identifies with the
hero and wishes to be loved by him every
girl projects their own personalities
onto her so it was weird playing the
part cuz I didn't feel like it was a big
departure I was there was no distinct
character I was playing I was really
just this girl this makes sense in light
of the way the Twilight fandom reacted
to Kristen Stewart in the role of Bella
Kristen Stewart was widely hated in the
role of Bella I think in part because
fans of Twilight didn't view her or
Bella as an ideal they could identify
with but rather as a kind of rival in
the book Bella is described in a mildly
depreciatory sort of way clumsy ordinary
this makes her not enviable and
therefore not an intimidating rival many
critics find Bella to be Bland but her
blandness is part of the appeal it suits
her rule as placeholder and then Kristen
Stewart ruined everything by being
gorgeous how dare she so let's contrast
the difference between two fantasy
structures the gender fluid
identifications of the feminine romance
Fantasy Versus the subject object
splitting of the male gaze John Berger
who coined the term male gaze says men
look at women women watch themselves
being looked at the surveyor of woman in
herself is male the surveyed female the
male gaze exemplifies what we could
tentatively call a masculine fantasy
type where you identify with a masculine
subject design Desiring a feminine
object and in the feminine fantasy type
identification is split between the
Desiring masculine subject and The
Feminine self as object of Desire so you
simultaneously identify with Edward and
you imagine yourself as the Beloved
object of Edward's desire a
distinguishing feature of the feminine
beloved fantasy is that in a sense the
object of Desire is yourself this has
led some people to conclude that
feminine fantasy is essentially
autoerotic or narcissistic deor says in
solitary pleasure it may happen that the
woman splits into a male subject and a
female object she describes a female
patient of psychoanalysis who said to
herself I'm going to love myself or more
passionately I'm going to possess myself
Margaret Atwood says you are a woman
with a man inside watching a woman you
are your own voer there definitely is an
autoerotic aspect of feminine fantasy
though I think it's unfair and
stigmatizing to say that narcissistic
love is specifically feminine like think
about the masculine concept of a trophy
wife is that not erotic narcissism a man
wants a beautiful woman because of what
having a beautiful woman says about him
or a pickup artist who wants a high body
count because that inflates his ego
Freud says that ego is the original
reservoir of the libido there's an awful
lot of narcissism to go around now that
I think about it there's many kinds of
narcissistic love there's I love that
you love me there's I love what I see of
myself in you there's I identify with
you and love myself as the object of
your love there's I love what having you
says about me it's like when Bella shows
up at school for the first time with
Edward as her cool new boyfriend proving
to everyone that she is cool too you
know everybody's staring it's totally
gorgeous obviously but apparently nobody
here is good enough for him but Bella is
Bella is good enough for him she has
what everyone wants even though she's
not the captain of the volleyball team
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding or the
president of the student council half
the feminine fantasy is loving yourself
Through The Eyes of the hero so the more
powerful and esteemed the hero is the
more elevated the woman becomes as his
beloved and you may as well shoot for
the moon Darcy is one of the richest men
in England Edward is a quote Godlike
creature a Perpetual savior the world's
most dangerous predator Christian Gray
is master of the Universe I feel like
this grandiosity compensates women for
being stuck playing second violin the
escalation into theology is just the
inevitable conclusion St Angela of
Felino claims Jesus told her my daughter
and my sweet spouse I love you so much
more than any other woman I'm not like
other girls in the eyes of God in Harry
Potter fandom there were these women
called Snape wives why is it always
Harry Potter can we do one video without
talking about Harry Potter Snape wives
believed that seus Snape was a literal
god with whom they could have a personal
erotic relationship on the astral plane
in her seminal paper on Snape wives Zoe
alerton quotes a Snape wife who claims
that seus Snape would use her husband as
a vessel during the physical act of love
so that while making love to her husband
she felt that she was metaphysically
making love to her Lord and Master seus
Snape and it seems like Snape was chosen
because these women identify with him
for the same reasons women have always
identified with Jesus because he has
relatable feminine coded trauma abused
humiliated penetrated even in the case
of Jesus but he also happens to be the
God who loves you it's like a fantasy of
being Mary in the P the feminine urge to
be daddy's Mommy so if you take the
feminine beloved fantasy to its extreme
this is what you end up with narcissism
escalated to theological proportions and
if you take the masculine lover fantasy
to its extreme you get objectification
to the point of predation this desire to
pursue and possess that can get a little
Jeffrey dmer a little Ted Bundy now
every generalization about gender and
sexuality is an overgeneralization and
I've been calling these two fantasy
types masculine and feminine because
that's how most people recognize them
but now we need to question the
assumption that lover equals masculine
and beloved equals feminine this
assumption is part of dhsm default
heterosexual St of mascul ISM and it's
oppressive and imprecise and I hate it
both straight and gay people frequently
conflate the diads masculine feminine
top bottom Dom sub lover beloved and
again I really want to emphasize that
masculine feminine refers to gender
expression top and bottom are sexual
positions Dom and sub are roles in a
power Dynamic and lover and beloved are
relationship rules that correspond to
different ways of structuring Desire the
lover is captivated by Beauty and
pursues it the Beloved either desires
the desire of the lover or
narcissistically enjoys thems as a
beautiful object as that which is
desired and pursued I don't buy the
anatomical Destiny argument that says
that men naturally pursue because their
Anatomy is pointed outward and women are
narcissists because their Anatomy is
pointed inward like do men not have
holes do men not have holes do women not
have external anatomy of Their Own
you can be a feminine top or a masculine
submissive or even a dominant bottom the
lover fantasy structure does not
inherently take a feminine person as the
Beloved but dhsm is so prevalent that
it's easy to make this mistake I'm sure
you can find examples of me doing it
like a lot of trans women early in my
transition I brought a lot of misery on
myself by unconsciously assuming that
women equals submissive equals attracted
to men which no this is cringe and
homophobic and misogynistic stop it I
forgive myself because this Prejudice is
extremely prevalent there are even
sophisticated theorists of gender that
slip into this even Simone deovir still
one of the best commentators on gender
ever in my opinion makes this mistake
she says quote man with his hard muscles
his scratchy and often hairy skin his
crude odor and his coarse features does
not seem desirable to women and he even
stir her repulsion if the prehensive
possessive tendency exists in wom more
strongly her orientation will be toward
homosexuality so she's conflating
femininity with the Beloved and just
assuming that women are not actively
attracted to coars hairy men Simone
that's just the lesbianism talking and I
mean same but this is our emotional bias
there are absolutely people some of them
women who go wild for hairy smelly
masculine bodies it's like their entire
thing in fact I can name it these three
people who are attracted to men now it
is interesting to ask what is left of
femininity when you separate it from its
associations with submission passivity
and the role of the Beloved that which
is desired is femininity just an
aesthetic I think gender expression is
not just aesthetic it's style and style
is more than aesthetic it's a way of
doing things like a dominant woman can
be a daddy Dom or a mommy Dom depending
on how she styles dominance we can maybe
say that femininity is a stylization of
the female and masculinity is a
stylization of the male dhsm is bad
first because it treats as equivalent
all these diads that are not even
necessarily correlated and second dhsm
is bad because it doesn't recognize the
versatility that is possible within each
diet dhsm assumes that in every
relationship one partner has to be the
man wear the pants and it also assumes
that that top bottom Dom sub lover
beloved are fixed binary roles which is
just not true in fact I think it's often
dysfunctional to suit sexuality in half
this way like in a common heterosexual
Dynamic the man desires the woman's body
and the woman desires the man's desire I
think this is dysfunctional because in
order to maintain the separation where
he is the subject and she is the object
the man has to degrade and objectify the
woman but the woman's ego is wounded by
the degradation so in order to
compensate she has to imagine that
instead of the mediocre schlub she's
married to she's instead surrendering to
the master of the universe her Lord and
Savior seus Snape I've noticed that even
conservative straight people reveal at
times a repressed longing for
versatility like so many straight men
who complain about male loneliness and
involuntary celibacy seem to think that
rning to traditional gender rules will
solve their problems but if you really
get into into it with these men it's
often clear that what's really eating
them up inside is that they've never
felt desired by a woman once in their
entire lives what they want is to feel
desired there's some part of them that
wants to be the Beloved but they don't
have the words for that it doesn't fit
into their idea of masculinity the
traditional gender roles they want to R
Vern to assign the Beloved role to women
and so many men feel that masculinity
requires them to be dominant and in
control all the time
but that's unbalanced you know learning
to enjoy submission builds character and
it's a valuable life skill don't we all
have to surrender in the end likewise a
lot of women yearn to explore the more
active verile side of sexuality in her
book girls who like boys who like boys
Lucy Neville argues that male male
erotica boys love slfi yahoi are very
popular among women in part because they
make more room for versatility and
fluidity than heterosexual ventions will
allow this channel is a fujoshi safe
space I say women's sexual
identification with men whether in slash
fiction or mainstream romance that
includes a male perspective I see it as
disproving a basic Assumption of dhsm if
women were just submissive by Nature why
would they sexually identify with men to
this extent even Stephanie Meyers
heterosexual world of Innocence has its
subversive gender fluid elements Edward
Cullen while in some ways a typical
lover father God figure of feminine
fantasy also has an alluring demure
feminine appeal he Sparkles he glowers
sometimes he needs rescuing don't women
sometimes want to pursue and enjoy a
beautiful person's body Bella clearly
does in Breaking Dawn Bella as a newborn
vampire becomes stronger than Edward
it's even implied that she becomes the
dominant it's your turn not to break
me top Bella is canon I arrest my case
so if even something as conservative and
thoroughly heterosexual as
Twilight contains a quiet but persistant
protest against dhsm then maybe dhsm has
got to go now I don't think abolishing
heterosexuality is realistic I would bet
a lot of money that for the foreseeable
future most men will continue to be
attracted to women and vice versa and
I've also argued that sedom masochism is
here to stay some people may find it
easy to embrace a tender egalitarian
sensuality but I think for most people
versatility is as close to sexual
equality as it's possible to get the
receiver becomes the giver and The Giver
becomes the receiver and it all balances
out I'm not saying that perfect equality
is possible there's no sexual Utopia on
the horizon but equality through
versatility is an ideal we can strive
for like American democracy you know
it's a thing we say we believe in and
God bless us for trying for me
versatility is is less about some
ideology of sexual maoism that says we
have to abolish all hierarchy it's more
just that I think we all contain
masculine and feminine potential within
us and it's more satisfying to express
both unlike bisi in proletariat or
colonizer in colonized I see masculinity
and femininity as a duality inherent to
human existence this by the way is why
trans women and feminine men are not
appropriating Womanhood women is not an
ethnic group and masculinity and
femininity belong to all Humanity now am
I saying that gender is binary no gender
is not a binary in the sense of 01 but a
duality in the sense of Yin Yang yin and
yang are interpenetrating opposites that
constitute each other there is no Yang
without Yin giving implies receiving
there is no doer without a done to there
is no top without a bottom yin and yang
consume each other as Darkness grows
light shrinks they transform into each
other night becomes Day Day becomes
night they're infinitely divisible Yin
contains Yang Yang contains Yin men
contain femininity women contain
masculinity and you can keep subdividing
and transforming there's fem tops and
mask bottoms there's power bottoms and
service tops femininity is supposedly
passive but isn't there activity in such
feminine gestures as inviting seducing
in exhibiting deuring receptive is a
better word than passive because
receptivity can be its own form of
activity pseudo questions like how many
genders are there or slogans like two
genders or even the well-intentioned
idea that gender is a spectrum I see all
of these as symptomatic of a
misunderstanding of Duality yin and yang
mean dark side and Light Side there are
two genders in the sense that there are
two sides of a mountain The Sunny Side
and the sh side there's still shade on
the sunny side and light on the Shady
Side depending where the mountain is the
Shady Side might become the Sunny Side
there is no shade without light so in a
sense the binary is non-binary in a way
it would be equally true to say that
there is one gender the human gender
that has been split into two into three
into many because yin and yang are
mutually dependent they're both a
duality and a Unity yin yang
now you might object won't this sort of
thinking turn us into a nation of cucks
are you trying to destroy masculinity
are you trying to destroy the West no
I'm not trying to cuck the West okay I'm
not trying to turn anyone into cuckolds
I'm trying to bring the West into
harmony with the da is that so wrong is
it possible Twilight isn't even about
romance could this all be an allegory
for a more spiritual Quest if a romance
novel dramatizes the internal struggle
to integrate the masculine and feminine
elements of ourselves then Bella and
Edward are not just characters they're
projections of our inwardly conflicted
nature the predator and the prey The
Lion and the lamb the lover and the
Beloved how can these be reconciled in
the last chapter of Breaking Dawn Bella
opens to Edward not only her body but
her mind Edward's vampire power is that
he can read minds but Bella's is that
she can Shield herself from other powers
it's because Edward could not read her
mind that he fell in love with Bella
because desire needs a boundary it needs
separation but at the end Bella says I
knew my shield better now I understood
the part that fought against separation
from me the automatic instinct to
preserve self above all else and she
begins to lower her Shield letting
Edward into her mind Simone says the
Supreme aim of human love like mystical
love is identification with the loved
one when all barriers fall the two
become one as their minds begin to meld
Bella thinks we continued blissfully
into this small but perfect piece of our
forever now you could call that cheesy
romance writing but sometimes you get
out of art what you put into it so I
prefer to see Twilight as a bold
statement about the paradoxical
equivalence of Love and Death and
immortality the end of separation is the
end of Desire it's life it's death it's
Unity it is the absolute it's perfect
forever
[Music]
for
and you've probably heard that JK
Rowling has a Twitter account now does
she really she did WOW have you ever
considered maybe in the future cuz I
know you don't have one now in the
future possibly getting on Twitter for
us absolutely not oh my gosh no I would
not be a good Tweeter I don't all the
cool authors are doing it I I'm not a
cool author I'm not Co I'm a nerd okay
can you imagine going to the grocery
store buying lettuce I I just I think
it's I'm kind of a private person when
I'm and I just don't think that people
need to know my every little dumb
thought that passes through my head